Irgendein Gate wird sowieso kommen, also ob das jetzt Bandgate oder irgendwas anderes ist.
Die Escape-Taste ist nicht mehr die obere linke Taste, sondern da ist jetzt eine...
Der Ein-
und Ausschalt-Button ist da.
Das Einschalter geht.
Power-Taste ist einfach mal fehl.
Der Bandgate, da gibt's doch wieder Leute, die sagen, wenn ich mich jetzt auf diesen Rechner draufsetze, dann verbiegt der sich. Aber wenn ich da mit meinem Hampi drüber fahre, dann verbiegt der.
Irgendein Gate wird sowieso kommen.
Es hat keinen MagSafe. Wie geht das? Wollen die auch hier so Laden machen über so eine Platte auf dem Tisch?
Nein, auch USB Type-C.
Ja, aber USB Type-C ist doch ein Trainwreck. Das Teil hält doch nie was aus.
Weil man nicht riecht aus dem Mund und unterm Arm.
Also ich kann mir nicht vorstellen, dass Apple die Dinger einbaut.
Ich kann mir wieder mein Rechner crashen, wenn da das Kleinkind übers Kabel schäubert und so.
Ich hab die furchtbare Befürchtung. Bis dann, tschüss So und jetzt noch mal alle, wenn ich nur gewusst hätte, wie das weitergeht, das Lied. Wusste ich irgendwie nicht. War mir unklar. Bin nicht textfest. Ich hab meine Lyrics nicht am Start. Ja und das in Zeiten von YouTube.
Hat der Teleprompter versagt.
Da kann man ja eigentlich alles auswendig lernen.
Der Teleprompter, was sagt der Ted?
Herzlich willkommen, hier ist die Freak Show. Ich zögere kurz. 149. Wieder so kurz vor so einem potentiellen Jubiläum, wo man immer nicht genau weiß, wie man damit umgehen soll. Das ist schwierig.
Ja, ja, ja, ja. No pressure. Ich mache alle heiß.
Ja, herzlich willkommen zur Freak Show, direkt und live und in Farbe, aus der Meta-Ebene aus Berlin.
In Farbe und Boom.
Der Berliner Podcast-Cluster, sozusagen am vollen Anschlag. Ja, und wir haben heute mal wieder eine neue Zusammenstellung. Mit wenig Überraschungen am Anfang. Du hast so eine Sendung mit der Maust-T-Shirt an. Das finde ich irgendwie ganz apart. Ist gut.
Da konnte ich nicht dran vorbei.
Ja, wo hast du das her?
Weiß ich nicht mehr, aber ich konnte nicht dran vorbei.
Aus dem Flagship-Store der Sendung mit der Maus.
WDR Flagship-Store.
Ja, das ist ein gutes Um, irgendwie. Das gibt so das Gefühl, du kannst Sachen ganz gut erklären. Huckel ist da.
Das stimmt, hast du richtig erkannt.
Was wurde dir alles so unterstellt, ob der, wie soll ich sagen, visuellen Dissonanz zwischen deiner Erscheinung im Video und deiner Stimme?
Alle haben gesagt, also bis auf Huckel und ich weiß gar nicht, wer es noch war, Tim wahrscheinlich, hätten die sich irgendwie die anderen alle anders vorgestellt. Also speziell Clemens und Roddy kamen irgendwie öfters in Gesprächen, von denen ich mir ganz anders vorgestellt hätte.
Wirklich? Aber bei dir war alles wie erwartet sozusagen.
Keine Klagen.
So sieht es aus. Dennis hat auch keine Klagen, oder?
Mir meint einer, dass er auch meinte, er hätte sich mich jünger vorgestellt.
Er hätte sich dich, mich, mir, jünger vorgestellt. Der, wo Jünger eigentlich vorgestellt hatte.
Wir sind hier in Berlin. Mit den Fällen.
So, weil Doppelt besser hält, haben wir noch einen Gast dabei. Denn Clemens ist heute nicht da. Clemens ist abwesend. Weil Clemens was dazwischen gekommen ist. Und deswegen haben wir gleich noch einen Dennis. Hallo.
Mein Lieblingskommentar aus der Sendung im YouTube-Account war, dass der Tim jetzt so alt aussieht unter der Freak Show Sendung, der einzige YouTube-Kommentar.
Der einzige?
Ja.
Echt? Oh, jetzt sehe ich so alt aus.
Tut mir leid.
Tut mir leid, dass ich so alt aussehe. Ich bin gar nicht so alt, eigentlich.
Steht ja alles in der Wikipedia, ne?
Ja, Dennis, Dennis Morhardt, Ed Gegelin. Ursprünglich war das doch mal richtig ausgeschrieben. GigaLinux, oder?
Ja. Und dann war mir der Nickname doof und dann hab ich die Vokale weggeworfen.
So wie Flügrr und Flüttr und...
Jetzt heiße ich halt GGLnix.
Okay. Und warum, warum vorher anders, also...
Alte Jugendsünde.
Machst du nicht mehr?
Nee, mach ich nicht mehr. Und das mit dem Giga ist ja auch schon vorbei. Damals.
Ich wollte grad schon fragen, Tim, was macht er hier, Windows, Linux? Also ich meine...
Naja. Das ist die Diversität. Die zieht jetzt hier auch ein. Ist ganz wichtig. Ja, ich hab dich eingeladen, weil du ja auch eine Menge zu erzählen hast und du warst ja auch auf dem Kongress und hast vor allem ganz fleißig beim Sendezentrum mitgewirkt. Das heißt, du bist auch nicht so richtig weggekommen vom Tisch?
Nee, nee, nee. Also ich hab den fatalen Fehler gemacht, mir die Keynote komplett anzuschauen und danach hab ich's mit den Vorträgen gelassen, weil ich gebrannt markt war.
Weil du dachtest, wenn das so ist.
Bin ich einfach im Sendezentrum geblieben. Nee, mein zweiter.
Tatsächlich? Und der erste war der neunzwanzigste?
Der dreizehntigste, ja. Ah.
Du bist ja gut eingestiegen. Warum warst du nicht vorher schon da?
Keine Ahnung.
Okay.
War nie die Gelegenheit, glaube ich.
Aber jetzt bist du abonniert sozusagen.
Ja, jetzt bin ich dabei. Jetzt bin ich angefixt.
Erzähl mal, wie war denn das, der Kongress? Kannst du das beide zusammenfassen?
Das ist eine interessante Erfahrung, weil plötzlich hat man das Gefühl, eigentlich normale Menschen. Bisher warst du, wenn man in der Schule rumgelaufen ist und die Computer gefixt hat und mal aus dem Unterricht durfte, weil der Lehrercomputer kaputt ist und der Einzige war, der den Linux-Server in der Schule beherrschen konnte. Man wurde ein bisschen komisch angeguckt und dann kommt man auf den Kongress und merkt, hier sind alle so. Man fühlt sich zu Hause. Das ist sehr schön. Und es ist halt ein riesiges Halligalli. Ich mag das. Du hast ja diese Vorträge, du hast diese Party gehabt. Ich hatte ja keinen Vergleich zu vorher, aber das, was ich da erlebt habe, dieses Hallo, wir heißen dich willkommen, egal wie du bist, wie du heißt, was du bist, mach mit uns spaßige Dinge.
Was hat diesen Eindruck bei dir erzeugt?
Na ja, man kommt in dieses Kongresszentrum rein und das erste ist das Flipboard, wo es Klack hat. So ein heimisches Gefühl direkt entsteht. Und dann kommst du rein, dann siehst du Leute an Rechnern und Dinge.
Ist das aus München?
Ne, bei Hannover. Ja, aber stand ja im Kongress...
Du redest jetzt von der Installation auf dem 30C3, ne? Wobei das selbe Ding war sicherlich auch wieder irgendwo...
Ich glaub jetzt ein bisschen weiter, vom Hacker-Space, oder?
Genau, vom Hacker-Space stand das rum.
Ja, das war wirklich sehr beeindruckend.
Ja, und hat geklackert.
Gibt's eigentlich in Hannover auch Hacker-Spaces?
Ich hab keine Ahnung. Also ich komm ja nicht aus Hannover, ich komm ja bei Braunschweig. Aber weil die Leute halt oft nicht wissen, wo Braunschweig ist, sag ich, ich komm bei Hannover.
Du kommst bei Hannover.
Das heißt, wir sehen uns auf dem nächsten Easter-Hack.
Ja, das nehm ich mir vor. Wieso? Weil der ist bei Braunschweig. Nee, die organisieren zusammen mit dem Hacker-Space aus Magdeburg. Den in unserer Jugendherberge oder so, zwischen deiner Pampa.
Okay, Easter-Hack, das ist dann zu Ostern. Und Ostern ist dieses Jahr wann nochmal?
Irgendwann im Frühling.
Im April?
Der Sonntag nach dem elften Vollmond nach Jahresanfang, oder wie war das?
Das ist der Braunschweiger-Gespräch.
Das ist der Jahresanteil nach dem Julianischen Kalender.
Stratum 0 ist der Braunschweiger? Und?
Der Magdeburger, den haben wir jetzt nicht im Kopf. Aber die sind beide zusammen drin.
Wie sind denn diese Zusammenfassung in Google immer besser als die Information auf der Seite, auf die man ankommt? Netz39.ev. Ach, guck an. Ja. Ich finde es ja schön, dass der Isaac so ein richtiger Wanderpokal geworden ist und nicht... Also es ist ja ursprünglich mal als Kongresskompensation in Hamburg entstanden. Und da war er dann...
Nachgebotsschmerzen erwähnt man so weit.
Nach wehen?
Nach wehen, ja, na ja, es war halt so ein Veranstaltungsmangel auf einmal da.
Verlusttrauma.
Ja, der wurde dann behoben und dann, ich weiß gar nicht, irgendwann ging das dann los, dass jede zweite Easter-Hegg-Sause woanders war und jetzt, wo der Kongress wieder in Hamburg ist, ist das so ein richtiger Wanderpokal. Das finde ich auch super. Der Ruby-Konferenz.
Auch so, aber 2014 sollte die in der Ukraine stattfinden und das konnte sie nicht so richtig wegen Gründen und dann fiel die aus letztes Jahr und es ist unklar, wie die sich wohl dieses Jahr manifestiert oder ob überhaupt. Also es war echt ein Schlag ins Gesicht, weil vorher ist die schön immer rumgewandert. Die hat, glaube ich, in München angefangen, dann war die in Krakau, in Barcelona, in Berlin, in Amsterdam schön rumgewackelt und jetzt halt mit Ukraine full stop. Naja, das kann eben im Easter Egg nicht passieren.
Aber bleiben wir noch mal kurz beim Kongress. Also, okay, also du bist reingekommen, bist jetzt geklackert und wusstest, du bist zu Hause sozusagen.
Ja, das hat man gefühlt. Nee, also ich hatte Sorgen, dass man da dann hinkommt und dann irgendwie doch nicht den Anschluss findet, aber das hat sich dann relativ schnell gelegt, weil man irgendwo, man ist so durch das Hackcenter gelaufen, hat sich dahingestellt, hat sich dann Dinge erklären lassen und ah, und toll. Und dann lag man dann irgendwann an Tag zwei die Nacht im Bällebad.
Gab es denn irgendwas, was dich überrascht hat?
Alles. Ich kannte es vorher nicht, deswegen hat mir alles überrascht.
Das war alles neu, aber ich meine, war irgendetwas ganz anders, als es dir gedacht hat, wie es sein müsste oder sein könnte.
Ich hab keine Ahnung.
Oder irgendwas, was dich nochmal über das schnell angewöhnte und was du als normal empfunden hast, was dann darüber hinausschoss. Gott, ich hab auch schon mal besser gefragt.
Ich glaube, Allen ist Heckcenter. Was da aufgebaut ist an Krämpeln, an Lasern, an 3D-Druckern, an Nähmaschinen. Dieses Jahr, die 31C3, diese Nähmaschinen mit 12.000 Stichen pro Minute, das ist schön.
Mit anderen Worten, du bist die totale Zielgruppe.
Ja, definitiv.
Wann hast du angefangen mit Rechnerwesen?
Ich hab zur Kommunion ein Aldi-PC bekommen.
Wann, wie alt ist man da?
Das war 2001. Das ist nicht die Frage. Da war ich 11. Oder 12. Genau.
Und da war es dann schon um dich geschehen.
So jung bist du? Ja, so in etwa.
Ja, das ist noch ein ganz junger Hüpfer. Ich weiß nicht, wie alt bist du jetzt?
23.
Und ich hab dich schon irgendwie total früh... Wo sind wir uns erstmal begegnet? Ich glaube in Jena kann das sein? Auf diesem WordPress-Event?
Ja, genau. Aber WordCamp im Jena, genau in diesem Tower.
Genau.
2009 oder 2008? Nee, 2008 war es in Hamburg. 2009 war es, meine ich. 2008 war es in Hamburg, das WordCamp.
Das war für mich total traumatisch, weil da war dieser Matt Mullenweg, dieser Typ, der irgendwie WordPress gekickt hat. Und dann bin ich gegen ihn angetreten im V-Tennis.
Oh ja.
Und ich hab dann im letzten Satz ganz knapp verloren. Das war wirklich hart für mich.
Das sieht man dir auch heute noch an, wenn du davon berichtest.
Das ist ganz schlimm. Ja, und da hast du dich nämlich schon mit WordPress beschäftigt.
Ja, das war dann mein drittes Jahr WordPress bereits.
Dein drittes Jahr?
Ja, ich hab mit 14 oder 15 mit WordPress angefangen.
Du bist groß geworden damit.
Ja, tatsächlich noch mit der 071 Gold Edition gearbeitet. Die hieß auch so, das war der erste WordPress Version.
War da irgendwas Gold dran?
Nee, das Backend war komplett grau. Aber es hieß halt Gold.
Ja, genau, und dann ging das irgendwie los mit diesem komischen Buddy-Press.
Ja, WordPress MU noch davor und es war lustig alles.
Ich hab da eigentlich den ganzen Tag nur den Kopf geschüttelt und mich gefreut. Wie kann man damit überhaupt arbeiten? Irgendwie hat mich das trotzdem interessiert. Jetzt bin ich ja auch gefangen.
Naja, manchmal kann man bei so einer Katastrophe auch nicht weggucken. Bei so einem Unfall.
So, und dann gibt es ja noch das Projekt. Ich spring jetzt ein bisschen. Ich muss hier mal zitieren. Anycast. Fachpodcast für Heimat, Recht, Baden und Moral.
Wie bitte noch mal?
Anycast, der Fachpodcast für Heimat, Recht, Baden und Moral. Fachpodcast.
Heimat, Recht, Baden und Moral.
Und Moral kommt einiges zusammen.
Das scheint mir so ein bisschen disjunkt zu sein, die drei Dinge.
Naja, zusammen mit Renke, Podcast-Macher, der ist Jurist oder angehender Jurist, der lernt noch. Das ist quasi der Recht, der. Dass, dass unsere 50er-Folge auf der Republika quasi der Wegweiser für Live-Podcasting auf einer Bühne wäre. Dabei saßen wir zu dritt, haben Pfeffi getrunken und im Hintergrund lief eine GIF-Animation oder eine GIF-Lupen-Animation.
Ja, da war schon einiges drin. Es gab eine Konfetti-Kanone. Und es gab überhaupt auch so Action auf der Bühne und so. Problem war natürlich, dass wir auf der Republika da so irgendwie eingesperrt waren in diese Höhle.
In die Kathedrale.
Diese komische Kathedrale, die auch akustisch entsprechend klang. Und das war irgendwie schon alles ein bisschen strange. So, und was hast du für ein Sportgerät?
Auf der Arbeit nutze ich ein MacBook Pro. Zu Hause und privat auf dem Handy Windows.
Warum?
Eigentlich ist es immer andersrum.
Ich weiß nicht, ich mag's. Ich hab's immer genutzt. Und funktioniert und...
Dirty pervert.
Und am Ende, ja, Stockholm-Syndrom. Und bisher hat dieses OSX auch mir nur Schmerzen bereitet. Ja, ich sag nur Audio, das ist alles tut weh.
Aber ich dachte bei Windows ist auch nicht alles gold, was...
Das ist noch schlimmer.
Aber wie, dann ist es noch schlimmer und dann findest du es bei OSX doof?
Ja, weil OSX mir verkauft, dass es funktionieren würde. Bei Windows verspricht es dir ja keiner. Das ist halt...
Was ist denn gut an Windows?
Na, es funktioniert halt. Also, wenn du ein funktionierendes System hast, dann würde ich es nicht wechseln.
Also jetzt mal ehrlich, unter uns jetzt sag mal. Wirklich.
Ich bin auch Verhechter von diesem Windows 8.1, das die Menschheit zum Kotzen findet. Ich mag diese Kacheln. Das bietet mir Mehrwert. Aber ich bin da auch wahrscheinlich...
Der Einzige.
Ich bin wahrscheinlich einmal als Kind auf den Kopf gefallen.
Du benutzt das ja auch auf deinem Telefon. Das fand ich einen besonderen Stunt.
Das ist ein sehr schönes Betriebssystem auf dem Telefon. Du hast halt vor allem komplett anderes Desktop oder Homestream Konzept. Wo du mit dem iPhone auf Android halt diese App-Icons hast, hast du auf dem Windows-Phone diese Kacheln, wo irgendwie dir die ganzen Informationen angezeigt werden. Es wackelt und du siehst halt alles auf einen Blick. Die Notifications...
Es wackelt.
Na, also die Kacheln drehen sich halt mal um und dann wird eine weitere Information angezeigt. Und so krempelt so Animation. Und es ist halt einfach ein Betriebssystem, was einfach sehr, sehr flüssig läuft.
Das stimmt allerdings.
Da hat Microsoft sehr viel Fleiß gezeigt, dieses System. Es kann aber auch Blue Screens, wenn man möchte. Das kann es auch noch. Es ist halt am Ende auch nur ein Windows.
Ja, also ich nehme das einfach mal so zur Kenntnis. Ich finde es ein bisschen verwirrend, muss ich sagen. Auch gerade so mit diesen ganzen Kacheln und so. Aber da bin ich wahrscheinlich auch der Falsche, das zu bewerten. Also ich schaue da nicht so wirklich auf.
Ja, ich habe ja bei mir auf dem Telefon zum Beispiel diese ganzen Notifications und auch am Homescreen die habe ich nur sehr sparsam enabled, weil eigentlich habe ich gar keinen Bock da die ganze Zeit so ein Notification-Opfer zu werden. Das Telefon liegt beim Arbeiten eben dran, du bist die ganze Zeit irgendwie so am Kicken.
Ja, wenn die Kacheln sich aktualisieren, kriegst du ja keine Vibration, sondern die machen das und wenn du dann irgendwann mal das Ding aufmachst, siehst du halt die Informationen, die du brauchst.
Die du brauchst?
Naja, du kannst ja die Kacheln so, du kannst ja in drei Größen die auf denen und das so irgendwie zusammenwürfeln, wie das passt. Du kannst da noch ein Bild hinterlegen und dann sieht das alles so schön fluffig aus.
Ja, hier sagt mir die Kachel gerade WLAN-Doppelpunkt 67 MB.
Genau, das ist die Verbrauchs-App, die Datenverbrauchs-App. So eine Storage-Sense, die andere heißt irgendwie anders. So Sense-Apps handeln die sich, glaube ich.
Ja, man kann ein Limit festlegen. Die Datenoptimierung hilft ihnen dabei, es im Auge zu behalten, sagt er.
Na, wenn er das sagt.
Was ist denn dein Podcast-Client mit Windows Phone?
Keins, das ist wirklich zum Kotzen. Also die Windows Phone Podcast-App, die mitgeliefert wird, die hat nicht mal eine Ansicht der neuesten Folgen oder die ungehörten Folgen.
Ja, die geht gar nicht.
Die ist kaputt. Deswegen, ich hab noch ein Android-Gerät als Zweitgerät so zum E-Testing und halt für die Apps, die es bei Windows Phone nicht gibt. Und da nutze ich halt Pocket Casts am Ende. Und das ist dann erträglich.
Das wird wahrscheinlich nicht auf Windows rauskommen.
Ich würds hoffen, aber ich glaube nicht, nein. Welche würd's jetzt demnächst besser binden?
Also mir ist so ein bisschen unklar, wer dafür jetzt eigentlich wirklich poämiert. Ich hab ja relativ viel Research gemacht, was so Podcast-Apps betrifft, auch auf Windows Phone. Ich hab ja hier so ein komisches HTC-Gerät, wo man, wenn man dann irgendwie so ein Developer-Programm unterschreibt, mit sagt, ja, ich will jetzt hier an deinem Web-Programm teilnehmen. Dann hat man da irgendwie so eine Autorisierung freigeschaltet. Und dann muss man noch irgendeine bekloppte abrunterladen, die heißt Insight, Insight irgendwie.
Ne, no, 3View for developers.
Und wenn man die runterlädt, dann kriegt man auch schon die System-Updates, obwohl die eigentlich für das Telefon gar nicht freigegeben sind.
Genau.
Das heißt, Microsoft hat so einen Weg drum herum geschaffen und die Telefonhersteller spielen da irgendwie mit.
So, das heißt, ich hab jetzt auch dieses WindowsPhone 8.1.
Das ist ja auch schon released. Da gibt es ja mehrere so Updates, die nennen sich dann irgendwie Crampel. Ich hab die Namen jetzt gerade nicht im Kopf. Aber übrigens sind es so Service Packs-artige Dinger. Nennen sie halt zum Glück nicht Service Pack, aber funktionieren jetzt so ähnlich.
Naja, dann ist halt so die Frage, wer entwickelt denn jetzt dafür eigentlich wirklich die ganzen Podcasts?
Zu wenig Leute.
Ja, die sind wirklich furchtbar. Also es kann dem kaum folgen. Es gibt relativ viele. Also es gibt da eine sehr lange Liste von Apps. Manche kriegen auch sogar Updates, aber man hat das Gefühl, da passiert eigentlich nicht sehr viel.
Naja, vor allem sind sie alle hässlich wie die Nacht.
Sie sehen auch alle gleich aus, das ist das Schlimme. Weil bei Windows Phone sieht alles gleich aus.
Naja, also Windows Phone hat ja sowas wie Design Guidelines, das hat ja Windows bisher noch nicht gehabt. Nur da hält sich auch keiner irgendwie Gefühl dran. Das ist halt dieselbe solche wie bei Windows, wo die Leute meinen, dass Guides halt kontraproduktiv wären und man sich nicht an Design halten müsste, sondern musste es selber machen. Man müsste Pink auf schwarzem Hintergrund machen, weil das schick aussieht und so. Die Seuche halt. Aber Microsoft ist leider in der misslichen Lage, dass sie alles in ihren App Store aufnehmen müssen, um irgendwie zu simulieren, dass da irgendwie Masse da wäre.
Das stimmt.
Hat Apple auch gemacht, also Poops-Apps und was war das, alle Taschenlampen-Apps und...
Microsoft kann sich noch nicht quasi Qualität statt Quantität erlauben.
Ja, aber denkst du, das wird noch was mit Microsoft?
Universal Apps ist das Keyword.
Ja.
Dass man quasi eine App hat, oder ein Entwickler kann eine App schreiben und zwar für Windows fürs Phone, Windows für Desktop, Windows für die Xbox, Windows für sonst was. Und eine Code-Basis und du hast dann dröffzig Milliarden Geräte, die du erreichen könntest. Oder dementsprechend ist der Markt so groß für deine App.
Da bin ich mal gespannt, weil das ist für manche Podcast-Apps tatsächlich angekündigt. Also es gibt zum Beispiel Bringcast, das ist irgendwie so eine App. Aber die ist bisher nur auf Windows Phones zu sehen und noch nicht auf Windows 8.1. Und ich hab auch so den Eindruck, auf Windows 8.1 benutzt irgendwie keiner.
Das ist alles noch so halb gar fertig. Also du kannst halt diese modernen Windows-Apps, so nennen sie die Dinge, also diese Metro-Apps, kannst du halt irgendwie nur auf dem Fullscreen nutzen und wenn du halt irgendwie so ein 26 Zoll-Display hast, willst du halt nicht Fullscreen arbeiten in so einer App, die halt für Touch optimiert ist und du hast eine Maus. Das ist halt der grandiose Fehler von Microsoft gewesen bei Windows und Windows 8. Zu sagen, ja, wir überwinden mal Maus und Tastatur und machen jetzt nur Touch-Only. Damit sind sie halt ja massiv auf die Fresse gefallen zurecht.
Aber was gibt denn dir das Gefühl, dass die da noch irgendwie...
Das Retten? Naja, weil sie seit einem halben Jahr so dieses Preview-Programm, was sie auf dem Windows Phone haben, jetzt auch auf dem Desktop haben. Und halt mit Windows 10 jetzt irgendwie alle zwei Wochen ein neues Release rausbringen und das wird immer besser.
Das heißt, du benutzt schon Windows 10?
Ich hab's installiert gehabt, ja. Aber nicht produktiv.
Ich hatte das auch mal installiert.
Und wann soll das rauskommen?
Die stellen das ja gerade vor, oder die haben es vorgestellt vor wenigen Minuten.
Was ist da dann anders?
Naja, die haben bisher, teilen sich ja Xbox, Windows und Windows Phone denselben Körner. Und ab Windows 10 ist das selbe Betriebssystem. Ein und dasselbe Betriebssystem. Das heißt, und die integrieren das halt so quer einmal durch und machen halt Windows zu so einem Service. Deiner Home-Plattform fu Krempel. Also nutzt du halt deine Windows-Phone-App, die hast du einmal gekauft, die läuft auch auf deinem Windows-Desktop, die läuft auf deiner Xbox und dann kannst du so, wupp, schlürfen, so Krempel machen, so Zeug halt.
Und wenn das Windows nichts mehr kostet, womit verdienen die dann ihr Geld?
Naja, App Store. Naja, das Windows kostet ja im ersten Jahr nichts. Die wollen halt die Leute damit holen.
Im zweiten Jahr dann abzocken.
Na, die werden halt auf irgendein Subscription-Modell umstellen. Das ist meine Theorie. Weil das machen sie bei Office schon, und damit sind sie sehr erfolgreich. Weil du zahlst Microsoft einen 60er im Jahr, kriegst dafür einen Terabyte Cloud-Speicherplatz, ein Office für fünf Systeme, fünf Installationsrechte, Keys. Und zahlst einen 60er dafür im Monat, und das reißen die Leute im Jahr. Und das reißen die Leute Microsoft wie warme Semmel aus den Händen. Und das werden sie mit Windows jetzt auch machen, einfach Subscription. Und dann gibt es quasi Updates im Background. Das heißt, dein System ist immer aktuell und du musst dich auch nicht so in einen Kreml nicht kümmern. Das ist auch nicht mehr diese Virenschleudern und so.
Und sie müssen nicht mehr in regelmäßigen Abständen ein neues Windows rausbringen.
Das ist das neue Microsoft.
Aber das finde ich erstaunlich, dass Microsoft tatsächlich geschafft hat, von mehrere Betriebssysteme auf einer Plattform zu ein Betriebssystem auf mehreren Plattformen.
Ja, ich glaube, das ist eher logisch am Ende, weil die haben sonst keine Alternative. Die müssen halt...
Die stehen mit dem Rücken zur Wand, genau.
Die haben halt ein mobiles System, was zwar irgendwie auf Platz 3 ist, aber halt weit abgeschlagen auf Platz 3. Das irgendwie in Deutschland ganz erfolgreich ist, weil diese Lumia-Handys sehr billig sind. Die verschleudern die ja schon ab 99 Euro und du kriegst halt irgendwie ein Top-Handy mit einem fluffigen Betriebssystem. Aber trotzdem will halt das keiner kaufen, weil die Apps fehlen. Dann sagt man sich noch gut, dann machen wir halt Universal Apps. Das geht jetzt schon unter 8.1, dass man eine App hat und die auf beiden Plattformpunkte nimmt. Jetzt ziehen die das halt tatt durch und machen das jetzt quasi zum Standard.
Na ja gut, also ich bin ja mal gespannt.
Und dann gibt es jetzt Windows 10 für Windows 7 User halt for free.
Wir laden ihn in zwei Jahren nochmal ein und gucken wir mal.
Also ich hab das Gefühl, dass die Strategie schon Sinn macht für Microsoft. Also es klingt erstmal jetzt nicht total verkehrt. Weil wenn du dir anguckst, ich meine, Google verschenkt sein Betriebssystem, Apple kriegt es auch mit dazu. Das ist halt schwierig jetzt den Leuten.
Ja, Apple verdient an der Hardware, Google verdient an der Werbung, Microsoft verdient an...
Ja, eben, genau. Genau, sie verkaufen eigentliche Betriebssysteme. Jetzt müssen sie den Leuten beibiegen, dass sie jetzt aber trotzdem bezahlt werden wollen. Und ich finde jetzt 60 Euro im Jahr klingt jetzt erstmal nicht so verkehrt.
Na ja, aber Microsoft hat ja nie wirklich viel Geld mit Windows verdient. Die haben immer sehr viel Asche mit Office verdient.
Das stimmt.
Und das tun sie immer noch. Und die werden halt einfach sagen, Windows ist unsere Plattform und sagen, wir geben dir halt kostenlos oder wir geben dir halt den Leuten, damit sie unsere Apps, unsere Services nutzen können. Und die ziehen das ja knallhart durch. Office gibt es ja auch fürs iPad, fürs Android-Tablet. In allen Variationen, die Apps sind ja alle super. Und die sagen so, wir verdienen einfach Geld an den Services. Und dieses Betriebssystem für die Geräte ist quasi Gimmick, damit die Leute unsere Services noch besser nutzen können. Ist halt dann am Ende quasi Marketing oder so.
Also ich kann das zwar nachvollziehen, dass sie diesen Weg gehen, aber dass das ihnen wirklich Erfolg bringt, da bin ich noch nicht so richtig von überzeugt. Weil sie stehen dann doch schon, wie sagtest du, mit dem Rücken zur Wand, naja, ist eigentlich noch ein bisschen schlimmer. Eigentlich haben sie diesen ganzen Mobilzug komplett verpasst.
Nee, die waren einmal zu früh da und dann sind sie eingeschlafen.
Wo waren die zu früh?
Na ja, die haben mit Tablets angefangen mal.
Die haben das schon vor x Jahren gemacht.
Ja und Windows Phone 6 und 5.
Und Windows CE gab es auch immer mal.
Also die waren halt immer, die waren mal da, haben es dann schlecht gemacht und sind dann, haben es dann gelassen.
Genau, die waren nicht zu früh da mit ihren Tablets, sondern die haben es verkackt. So muss man das sagen.
Früh verkackt und dann gelassen.
Aber du hast ja noch was anderes Gutes getan. Und zwar hast du ja der deutschen Podcast-Community eine Diskussionsplattform geschenkt, sage ich jetzt mal so. Also der eigentliche Auslöser war natürlich Ralf. Hallo Ralf.
Hallo.
Ja, das fand ich ja ein bold move, muss ich sagen.
Das erste Forum, in dem sich Tim seit Jahren wieder angemeldet hat.
Ja, in der Tat.
Qualitätsstandard.
Ja, also wir reden von Send The Gate.
Ist glaube ich nicht der beste Name aller Zeiten. Also ich habe dir einen Witz mittlerweile erklärt im Forum. Es gibt einen Thread, wo jemand gefragt hat, was es denn überhaupt bedeutet. Und ich war dann ein Spielverderber und hab's aufgeklärt. Aber wir können es jetzt für jetzt auch belassen. Müssen wir ja nicht erklären, oder?
Ja, nee, nicht unbedingt. Also es heißt einfach Sendegate und das Sendegate ist quasi das Tor zur Welt des Senden und Empfangs. Und naja, ich bin ja nun kein Freund von Webforen, aber ich will mir auch nicht vorwerfen, das nicht wäre unbelehrbar. Hier kommt ja eine Software zum Einsatz, die heißt Discourse. Und Discourse ist wiederum von den Leuten, die Stack Exchange, Stack Overflow gemacht haben.
Also dieser Jeff Edward hat ja Stack Overflow mitgegründet und hat dann quasi mit noch anderen Leuten dieses Open Source Projekt Discourse gegründet. Und sagte, wir müssen jetzt Webforen mal richtig machen und wir haben mit Stack Overflow gelernt, wie es geht. Und das Wissen stecken wir da jetzt rein.
Aber die Funktionalität von Stack Overflow ist als solche nur so eingeschränkt da drin.
Na ja, Stack Overflow ist ja kein FOM, sondern eher so eine Nolge-Community, so wir müssen hier Fragen beantworten, dass es dann hier tatsächlich Diskussionen in geordnete Bahnen lenken, was ziemlich gut funktioniert, gefühlt.
Aber man kann nicht, oder gibt es das auch, dass man so antworten, hochvoten kann und so?
Das ist so nicht drin. Das ist nicht drin. Ich glaube, es gibt irgendwie ein Plug-in, was irgendwie rumgeistert ist, könne.
Was würdest du denn so, also, kennt ihr das? Rest am Tisch?
Stackoverflow.
Nee, Discourse.
Also Stackoverflow.
Ich kenne das Sendegate.
Da hast du auch schonmal drin rumgeklickt.
Ja, ich hab mich auch angemeldet.
Naja, also das Coole ist, erst mal das Ding fühlt sich mal mehr so an, wie so eine richtige Web-Applikation. Also man klickt da schon mehr so im Code rum, als nur auf irgendwelchen rausgerinnerten HTML-Seiten, wie das so bei Webforum ja normalerweise ist. Also das ist das, was mich immer so total fertig gemacht hat. Vor allem diese unglaublichen Noises, also du hast in so einem Webforum, wenn du auf so einen Thread blickst, dann ist so 95% des HTML-Inhalts ist so repetitiver Wiedergabe von immer demgleichen Kram, Trennlinien, Icons, Avatare.
Diskurs wirbt damit folgendes Feature nicht zu haben, und zwar Signaturen. Es kann keine Signaturen und Stolz drauf. Das ist eine Errungenschaft, für die Leute Jahrzehnte gekämpft haben, die Signaturen abzuschaffen in Foren. Aber so andere Dinge, die so eine Community vergiften können, gibt es da auch nicht. Es gibt nirgends, wo angezeigt wird, wie viel Beiträge ein Nutzer oder eine Nutzerin geschrieben hat. Weil es dann direkt so ein, ich hab 1000 Beiträge geschrieben, ich hab hier die dicken Klöten, und jetzt mach mal nach meiner Pfeife, Effekt dann halt nicht gibt. Die Leute sind halt dann auf einer Ebene. Es gibt halt dann eher so ein Belohnungssystem mit Abzeichen. Das heißt, wenn du einen Beitrag schreibst, der ganz viele Herzen gesammelt hat, dann gibt es ein Abzeichen. Wenn du den ersten Beitrag geschrieben hast, gibt es ein Abzeichen. Wenn du die ersten 100 Beiträge gelesen hast, gibt es ein Abzeichen und so Dinger halt. Und dann kannst du über so Reproduktionspunkte, du liest viel, kannst du halt Stufen sammeln. Mit der Stufe erlangst du mehr Rechte im Forum im Sinne von, du kannst mit Stufe 3 Moderations-Tätigkeiten übernehmen. Das heißt, du hast eine selbst regulierte Community. Wo Leute, die aktiv sind, quasi belohnt werden mit Moderationsrechten und quasi dann noch ein bisschen weiter. Das muss man alles konfigurieren. Das Sendegate ist in Sachen Belohnungs- und Community-Management-Settings in den Grundeinstellungen immer noch. Das heißt, Leute starten bei uns in eine Stufe, ich meine in Stufe 1 und werden nach den ersten 10 gelesenen Beiträgen in Stufe 2 geworfen. Und dann müssen sie bestimmte Quoten erfüllen und dann können sie sich hocharbeiten in Stufe 3. Ab Stufe 3 können sie halt Beiträge moderieren zum Beispiel. Und so Dinge halt.
Also es ist wirklich sehr interessant. Es gibt auch private Nachrichten. Also man kann so... Weiß ich gar nicht, wie heißt denn das?
Das Nachrichten ja. Die funktionieren genauso wie normale Frets. Das heißt mit den ganzen komfortablen Features und so. Und beim Sendegate auch aktiviert per E-Mail antworten, was bei den privaten Nachrichten halt ganz nett ist. Dass man direkt im E-Mail client auf private Nachrichten antworten kann. Dann sind das so die kleinen Features, die es sehr schön machen.
Genau, also wenn irgendjemand von euch da draußen eine Podcast-Frage hat, dann würde ich fast sagen, ist das jetzt schon so der beste Ort, wo man das unterbringen kann.
Definitiv.
Erstaunt, wie viel Aktivität da ist. Hast du da irgendwelche Statistiken?
Ja, du kannst neben deinem Namen auf das Hamburger-Icon klicken. Und da gibt es eine Seite, die nennt sich Über. Und da gibt es Zahlen.
Ach, ich bin ja hier. Feder steht hier.
Klick mal erneut versuchen. Ah, irgendwas ist da kaputt. Ist immer noch in Beta die Software, deshalb kann immer noch kaputt gehen.
Die Default-Ausrede.
263 Themen.
Genau. Und über 4000 Beiträge in diesen Themen. Mit fast 400 Nutzern, das ist schon ordentlich.
Du bist Administrator?
Der Tim ist Administrator.
Ja, ich bin nicht nur in einem Web-Forum, ich bin sogar Administrator in einem Web-Forum.
Wow, weit gebracht hast du es.
Ich steige auf.
Ich nehme mal an, Leute, die sowas installieren, können bei bestimmten Usern auch gleich das Admin-Fleck klicken.
Ja, da geht auf jeden Fall was. Ja, nee, das ist schon ganz hilfreich. Das ist jetzt vor allem alles in Deutsch. Es gab auch so die Anfrage, ob man das nicht auch in Englisch machen sollte, könnte. Aber ich glaube, so bilinguale Foren funktionieren nur sehr eingeschränkt.
Ja, das ist ein Milchmasch am Ende. Da aktiviert man irgendwie ein Login für alle Plattformen. Das kann man ja machen in Discourse. Und macht dann getrennte Foren, wo man dann sein Login halt teilt, dass man sich mit einem deutschen Login im englischen Forum und dann umgekehrt einloggen kann. Das geht, ja.
Das heißt, wir könnten die englische Variante quasi auch alle User automatisch übernehmen, aber man hätte eine andere Basis. Das sollte man vielleicht sogar tun. So, und was musste man dafür installieren? Also, das ist ja jetzt...
Das Discourse ist Rails. Das war's. Mehr braucht das nicht.
Zwei Datenbanken.
Naja, Redis halt für so Background-Tasks ablegen und Caching-Krempel. Weil Redis liegt halt im Speicher, der Postgres halt nicht.
Redis ist nur Memory Only, oder was?
Das schreibt auch auf die Disk, aber immer nur so im Background, so falls mal irgendwie Strom aus, dass du wieder anfängst. Also dann lädt er sich wieder den Dump wieder rein und dann ist aber alles im Speicher und Key Value. Also Redis benutzen wir bei VUGA auch sehr viel. Tatsächlich ist es eine coole, schnuffige Datenbank und eins der wenigen IT-Projekte, das rockt und aus Italien kommt. Naja, der Typ zumindest, der Redis sich ausgedacht hat, ist Italien. Ich weiß gar nicht, ob der da noch lebt, aber wahrscheinlich schon. Redis ist auch eine Datenbank, die oder ein Software-Projekt, das irgendwie eine coole Doku hat. Ich mag die Art, wie sie so die Doku strukturiert haben. Weil du kannst halt, da gibt es so ein paar Datenstrukturen, ich glaube redis.io oder sowas ist das. Und dann kannst du oben bei Documentation oder bei Commands klicken wir da links oben. Und dann gibt es da halt erstmal alle Commands und dann kannst du aber oben noch sagen, ich will jetzt nur alles für Hashes oder nur für Lists. Und dann kriegst du halt nur für die jeweiligen Datenstrukturen auch so deine Commands und siehst auch gleich auf Einblick, was die so tun und was es so für Operationen gibt. Und weil die halt sehr schnell ist und im Speicher, es gibt halt nicht viele Operationen, es gibt so Unions und Sets und Order Sets. Also es gibt so ein paar nützliche Datenstrukturen. Und dann siehst du halt hier irgendwie relativ fluffig gleich, was du mit einer oder mit der jeweiligen Datenstruktur so anstellen kannst. Und irgendwie macht dich das halt so relativ übersichtlich, relativ leichtgewichtig, aber man kann schon einen coolen Scheiß damit machen. Ist halt nicht so wie jetzt, sagen wir, Postgres, wo du halt wirklich irgendwie zwei Jahre lang irgendwie in der Doku stöbern kannst und immer noch nicht alles weißt wahrscheinlich. Das ist so, bei Red ist alles ganz fluffig. Aber es hat natürlich auch Konzept, dass sie nicht viel macht. Aber das, was sie macht, schnell und siehschau. Oder zumindest zuverlässig. Kann man empfehlen. Also ich mache ja hier bei VUGE öfters mal so Job-Interviews, wo ich die Leute so ein bisschen ausfrage, mit was sie sich schon beschäftigt haben. Und mit Redis, also wer sich mit Redis noch nie auseinandergesetzt hat, der sollte sich das schon durchaus mal angucken. Da gibt es auch, weil Tim hier gerade in der Client-Sektion, es gibt eigentlich auch für alle Sprachen und für alle Runtimes irgendwelche Clients schon. Und das Protokoll ist halt auch relativ easy. Also man kann auch relativ schnell sich einen eigenen Redes kleinschreiben. Das ist wirklich alles ganz fluffig.
Die Erlang-Anwendung kommt von Vugar.
Eine davon, ja.
Swift gibt es noch nicht.
Hast du da was mit zu tun?
Ich habe da bestimmt auch mal eine Zeile irgendwo ver- Also ich weiß nicht, ob die da in dem Repo gelandet ist, aber ja, der Kollege, der das gemacht hat, den kenne ich wohl.
Alles dabei. Also man braucht Redis, man braucht Postgres, man braucht Robi, Rails.
Dann läuft dann irgendwie noch ein Engine X und verwendet das irgendwie alles. Und weil sich die Leute bei Discourse dachten, so Intentationsanleitungen, die aus 20, 30, 40 Commands bestehen, sind halt doof, nehmen wir Docker und sagen, Leute, das ist unser Docker-Container, der ist fertig eingerichtet, der funktioniert. Da ist nun alles so konfiguriert, dass ihr es nur starten müsst. Am Ende macht ihr noch Port-Forwarding und dann funktioniert es.
Ich finde ja sowas immer ein bisschen bedenklich, aber auch gleichzeitig. Es ist zwar schön, dass man so einen komplexen Hobel irgendwie auch mit einem Klick hochfahren kann, aber ich finde es immer nicht so gut, wenn die Leute sich nicht damit beschäftigen, was sie da eigentlich fahren und dann ist es plötzlich langsam und down und irgendwas crasht und dann sitzen alle so da, ja, keine Ahnung, vielleicht. Naja, nee, so eine, hier klick einen Button und alles funktioniert und wir richten das schon für dich ein und konfigurieren das schon. Was wisst ihr denn über meinen Use-Case? Also ich bin immer so einer, der lieber selber mal das Config-File liest und die Kommentare und dann halt die Option anklickt, die man so haben will halt.
Du weißt, wenn die User Fragen haben, dann kommst du auch gerne mal im weißen Kittel mit dem Klemmbrett so, mit der Tür vor und dann so, ja, guten Tag. Wie geht es uns denn heute?
Wo ist denn das Steinchen da im Schuh? Ne, aber ich mein, ja, ist ja...
Legen sie ihre Lochkarten bitte dort hinten ab. Ich finde, das ja durchaus hat ja so einen demokratisierenden Effekt, wenn die Dinge auch einfach mal aufzusetzen sind. Aber ich verstehe schon, dein Einwand ist ja eher ganz praktisch, dass...
Ich bin halt immer der Überzeug oder der... Also ich finde persönlich, dass man das, womit man vielleicht so auch unter anderem sein Geld verdient, man sollte schon irgendwie wissen, was man da auch so betreibt. Und es sind ja auch so bei diesen ganzen Cloud-Providen, Amazon hat jetzt ja auch Datenbanken und alles, und wir schieben ja zum Beispiel auch einige Sachen so teilweise eben auch in die Cloud und lassen das halt irgendwie irgendwie so eine Firma für uns alles hosten und machen. Und ich habe zum Beispiel also persönlich kein so tolles Gefühl dabei, wenn irgendwie so ein Core-Teil meines Businesses zum Beispiel einfach da irgendwo ohne Kontrolle läuft. Und wenn halt zum Beispiel gerade bei Amazon oder so, wenn irgendwas langsam ist oder du Lochfraß auf der Platte hast, versuch da mal halt Support-Zeiten heranzukriegen und musst halt immer jemand haben, der von außen da vom Hostsystem reinguckt für dich, weil du halt nicht rausgucken kannst. Du siehst halt nur die Effekte dann da drin in deinem kleinen Container. Und so ja auch hier so eine One-Click-Perspektive oder der Favorit von mir ist ja hier so irgendwelche Pakete oder Programme, die sagen so hier klickt den Button und dann ist alles sicher. So irgendwie so Personal Firewalls oder was auch immer. VN-Scanner sind jetzt so die Extrembeispiele für so gerade mit Sicherheit muss man sich ja selber irgendwie ein bisschen auseinandersetzen, bevor das alles funktioniert. Und deswegen bin ich immer so einfach von dieser Grundeinstellung bei diesem hier klick mal da und dann hast du so ein System und wir haben schon alles für dich konfiguriert, bin ich immer so ein bisschen so ich hab es tatsächlich probiert, weil ich dachte so Doktor, na Doktor, na, ich hab Doktor gehört, aber ich wollte damit nicht drum spielen, ich mach das selber.
Ich installiere dieses Diskurs selber, hab danach 6 Stunden aufgegeben, weil halt dann für Debian das passende Postgres-Paket nicht verfügbar war und das ist halt so ein Giraffel war das. Und dann hab ich mich dann für Doktor beschäftigt eine Stunde und hab den Container hochgefahren und dann lief das Ende-Gate und war dann so, ja, so unklug ist das ja auch nicht alles. Aber ich weiß, was da drin passiert, weil ich das jetzt schon einmal debuggen musste.
Wie behauptet man, also was ist denn dieses Docker eigentlich genau?
Naja, Docker ist so ein in Go geschriebenes Command Line Interface für Linux-Containers und Linux-Containers ist halt so eine Art... Jail, genau, ja ungefähr.
Aber mit mehr Isolation glaube ich, das heißt es benutzt halt keine Shared Base Systems oder was auch immer. Also wenn du da drei Docker-Instanzen hast, dann haben die auch den kompletten Memory Footprint des ganzen Stacks und nicht so wie zum Beispiel jetzt bei FreeBSD, wo halt so das Base System und so verschiedene Teile immer in die Jails so mit reingelinkt werden und dann noch einmal das Ganze rumlegen hast, ich glaube bei Docker ist das alles sehr viel mehr isoliert.
Na ja, die teilen sich halt den Kernel am Ende. Du kannst halt nur Lieblingsdrehungen laufen lassen, die sind nickern. Aber das ist halt in den Prozess-Ebenen so sauber getrennt, das heißt jeder kriegt seine eigenen Ressourcen. Wenn man in halt dieses Containers ist, von Docker, kommst du halt auch nicht raus wieder. Das wirkt halt wie ein eigenes System, ist bis drinnen abgesperrt. Und das ist halt ganz, so Heroku zum Beispiel nutzt Linux-Containers im Hintergrund, um ihre Systeme hochzufahren. Bei Virtualisierung hast du halt so ein Overhead. Du musst halt diese Maschinen aufrecht erhalten und so Dinge. Und bei Linux-Containers hast du halt mit so einem Overlay-Filesystem, das heißt, jetzt hast du halt einen Container und kannst sagen, der zweite Container stammt von dem ersten Container ab und da werden halt noch die Differenzen auf dem Filesystem gespeichert. Das heißt, wenn du zweimal Ubuntu hast in einem Container und in einem Container speicherst du eine Konfiguration anders ab, dann ist tatsächlich nur diese Konfiguration gespeichert und nicht zweimal Ubuntu auf deiner Platte. Das ist ein Overlayer. Du sagst einfach, das ist der Basiscontainer und alles andere wird davon abgeleitet.
Auf welcher Ebene wird diese Differenz gebildet?
Auf Filesystem-Ebene.
Auf Datalsystem-Ebene. Und das unterstützt das Datalsystem selber?
Ja, die liefern ein eigenes Datalsystem mit. Das nennt sich dann Overlay FS. Und damit kann man ganz fluffig arbeiten. Im Gegensatz zu einer Virtualisierungskiste hast du diesen Overhead nicht. Dein Prozess in diesem Linux-Container sitzt direkt am Kernel dran. Und direkt am Prozessor. Du musst nicht durch einen virtualisierten Prozessor gehen, der dann wiederum den anderen, den richtigen Hauptprozessor anspricht.
Hauptprofessor.
Klingt ja eigentlich ganz sinnvoll, oder?
Ja, also ich würd, also sagen wir mal so. Das ist auf jeden Fall, es gibt ja so, zum Beispiel wenn du selber einen Server betreibst und da verschiedene Services voneinander isolieren willst, aber alles deins ist zum Beispiel, wird da glaube ich immer noch die Jails bevorzugen, aber wenn du halt schon irgendwie so ein bisschen diverse Sachen da betreiben willst und vielleicht auch von anderen Leuten, dann ist Docker oder diese Linux-Containers bestimmt, also definitiv besser als wirklich eigene Virtual Machines die ganze Zeit hoch und runter zu fahren.
Aber warum würdest du die Jails bevorzugen?
Weil es noch leicht gewichtiger ist und im Prinzip die genug Isolation zwischen den einzelnen Varianten bietet. Also Docker ist schon, zumindest ich hab's jetzt noch nicht so viel angeguckt, aber was ich so von Kollegen, die haben sich das mal angeguckt und auch so eine kleine Präsentation in der Firma darüber gehalten, das klang so, als wäre da schon noch so ein bisschen, wie gesagt, noch ein bisschen mehr Isolation zwischen den Instanzen als bei Jails. Die Jails sind ja wirklich so ein ganz dünner Layer der Separation.
Aber wahrscheinlich kann man in so einem Linux-Container auch alles machen, während es ja in den Jails durchaus Einschränkungen gibt. Ich erinnere mich da, lange Zeit war das mit IPv6 ein Problem und Localhost gibt's da irgendwie nicht.
Na doch, mittlerweile gibt's auch Localhost.
Mittlerweile gibt's das alles.
Gibt auch, ja, man kann auch pingen im Jail und so. Das gibt's alles schon mittlerweile. Na ja, es hat ja praktische Gründe, warum. Raw Sockets kannst du für Jails schon seit acht, glaube ich, oder mindestens seit acht, freischalten.
Aber musst du sonst jetzt irgendwie, ja?
Einfach ein Jail-Parameter. Also der Grund, warum man nicht pingen konnte, ist halt sonst, dass du keine Raw Sockets in den Jails kriegst, weil du halt sonst den Traffic von potenziell anderen Kunden oder was auch immer mitschnüffeln kannst. Aber wenn du, wie ich gerade meinte, so einen Mailserver betreibst und deinen Spam-Checker, deine Datenbank, dein Webfrontend, dein SMTP und IMAPD in eigenen Jails fährst, wo sozusagen alles dir gehört, dann kannst du auch die Sockets auf Raw schalten und dann ist es halt auch egal, dass die Jails jetzt, sagen wir mal, den Traffic von den anderen Jails sehen. Aber, ja. Also das war eigentlich so der Hauptgrund, warum man im Jail nicht pingen kann, weil es halt keine extra virtuellen Interfaces gibt, sondern du benutzt halt die Interfaces. Naja, aber, ja, ich meine, ich benutze sowieso Jails lieber, weil ich halt so ein alter Freebies-Dealer natürlich bin. Und die Linus-Containers, zum Beispiel die Travis CI-Jungs, die hatten ja hier dieses Hosted Continuous Integration-Ding aus Berlin, was auch bei GitHub mittlerweile ziemlich gut integriert ist. Die hatten auch am Anfang für ihre Build-Instanz natürlich probiert irgendwie, wie können wir jetzt irgendwie möglichst leichtgewichtig da dauernd irgendwelche Environments hochfahren, wo die Leute ihre Tests fahren können. Und die haben am Anfang mit Linux-Containers gespielt, das war, weiß nicht, mittlerweile vor vier Jahren oder drei Jahren. Und da waren diese Linux-Containers noch in einem eher merkwürdigen Zustand, also da stand schon viel auf der Kiste drauf, aber an Features, aber in der Realität war das nur schwer wirklich zum Funktionieren zu bringen. Und das hat sich, glaube ich, in den letzten drei Jahren auch überhaupt erstmal so richtig in den Zustand der vollumfänglichen Funktionierung begeben. Wohingegen die Jails ja in Fribes, die jetzt auch schon seit, weiß nicht, 10, 20 Jahren drin sind und halt schon auf jeden Fall gut abgehangen sind. Kennst du nicht hier Travis CI? Du bist jetzt auf com, geh mal auf org.
Die kommen ja auch aus Berlin. Und die haben jetzt tatsächlich auch auf Docker umgestellt.
Genau, weil die hatten halt die ganze Zeit, weil eben diese Linux-Containers am Anfang so scheiße waren und Zeit verbrannt haben, haben die halt am Anfang gesponserte Virtual Machines die ganze Zeit hochgefahren. Und als das immer populärer wurde, war das halt nur noch schwer mitzukriegen. Falls du das noch nie gesehen hast, Tim, du kannst jetzt quasi dich da einloggen mit GitHub und dann, wenn du eine Test-Suite in deinem Projekt hast, kannst du so einen kleinen Schalter umlegen, also der fetched deine GitHub-Projekte. Dann kannst du da sagen, hier, dieses Projekt würde ich jetzt gerne mal bei euch automatisch testen und immer wenn du committest, dann läuft das da. Und du kannst sagen, welche Dependencies da noch mitlaufen sollen und der macht da ein Continuous Integration. Für jeden Commit gibt's ein Bild. Und das Geile ist, wenn jemand auf GitHub ein Pull-Request macht für ein neues Feature in deinem Projekt, dann wird das automatisch auf Travis CI schon sozusagen getestet. Und du kriegst den Pull-Request mit so einem kleinen Icon hier, Bild läuft durch, kannst einfach reinmergen sozusagen. Also es ist wirklich...
Bricht deinen Code nicht sozusagen.
Genau, zumindest deinen Testcode, den du geschrieben hast, vielleicht bricht's an einer Stelle, die du nicht getestet hast, aber prinzipiell ist der Workflow mit denen echt fluffig.
Ich glaube, beim Publisher läuft das auch, das Travis CI. Ja, meine ich. Meinerlich habt ihr den grünen Button da gesehen, aber ich kann mich jetzt auch täuschen.
Der Tim codet ja nicht, der managt ja nur noch. Ja, auf jeden Fall, die hatten am Anfang, wie gesagt, mit Linux-Containers noch größere Bauchschmerzen.
Was frisst das so an Ressourcen weg, so ein Discourse, wenn das in so einem Docker-Modul installiert ist?
Das läuft stabil bei 2 GB RAM.
Also, wenn ich es richtig verstehe, also du hast quasi eine Linux-Büchse, die fährt mehrere Container.
Genau.
Und dieses Docker ist eigentlich mehr so ein Modulmanagement, wo man sagt, ich habe hier jetzt Discourse als Docker-Modul.
Als Container, genau.
Okay, als fertigen Container, mach mal. Und dann holt er sich die ganzen Dependencies auch noch mit rein und das sind dann auch einzelne Container, dieses Redis und so.
Nee, nee, das ist, also das kann man machen. Also es gibt ja verschiedene Schulen der Docker-Administration, dass man tatsächlich die Services auch wirklich sauber wegtrennt und man kann in Docker halt die miteinander reinhängen und sagen, hier, nutze bitte MySQL, nutze bitte Postgres, nutze, hm, das kann man alles da reinhängen. Aber Docker ist halt so, du kriegst halt dieses, äh, sorry, Diskourse, installierst du das und dann baust du dir einen Container auf der Konsole mit deinen Einstellungen vor. Du musst halt so E-Mail-Settings so einwerfen, so eine YAML-Datei, und dann baut du dir so einen Container und den kannst du dann einfach rauf und runter starten. Dieses rauf und runter starten dauert wenige Sekunden. Aber das Bauen selber des Containers, das dauert schon zwei, drei Minuten, weil er dann tatsächlich einmal Datenbank installiert, einmal bei Rails die ganzen Games installiert, einmal die ganzen Assets, also JavaScript und CSS vorgeneriert und das alles schon abgelegt in Cache, einmal kurz alle Mail-Settings durchtestet und wenn er damit durch ist, legt er halt quasi so ein Abbild dieses Containers auf die Festplatte ab und den kann man dann rauf und runter starten.
Warum? Übrigens der grüne Button, den du gesehen hast, war ein Flatter-Button bei GitHub, weil wie ich sehe, hat der Podlof-Publisher gar keine Tests oder wie. Das heißt, es würde gar keinen Sinn machen, das auf Travis CI laufen zu laufen.
Der hat Tests, aber da will man glaube ich nicht drüber sprechen. Das ist halt die wilde Wordpress-Welt der jungen Tests. Das ist alles kaputt.
Naja, wie das ebenso ist mit diesen PHP-Projekten. Aber bei Travis CI kann man tatsächlich wirklich alle möglichen Projekte und Sprachen und sonst was laufen lassen. Das ist nicht der Grund, warum es da keine Tests gibt.
Also was würdest du empfehlen, was das Podlauf-Projekt tun sollte?
Naja, das ist jetzt...
Windbrunnen gefallen.
Das ist jetzt schon zu spät. Also niemand schreibt jetzt noch hinterher Tests, ne? Naja, sagen wir mal, die Erfahrung zeigt. Das ist so wie Murphy's Law. Das ist einfach eins dieser ungeschriebenen oder undokumentierten Gesetze. Aber es ist oft wahr. Und ich meine, wenn... Es kann ja auch wirklich sein, dass jetzt zum Beispiel Erik hört jetzt vielleicht zu und sagt so Ja, ich würde ja gern oder er hat ja auch letztes Mal irgendwas erzählt so in der Richtung, dass diese ganzen Testing-Frameworks und dass das gerade erst überhaupt so da ins PHP-Mainline irgendwie mit Einzug erhält.
Nee, nee, also im PHP sind Unit-Tests schon uralt. Also im PHP-Unit gibt es ja immer noch Äbigkeiten. Beim Wordpress hat man das für nicht notwendig betrachtet. Und erst seit einem Jahr macht man das Hardcore.
Na gut, aber das würde ja Erik nicht davon abhalten zu testen, oder?
Nö. Es gibt ja auch ein paar Tests. Aber die sind halt incomplete.
Aber man muss sie suchen.
Naja, er meinte letztes Mal, dass er das versucht hat. Und die sind ihm so oft gebrochen, dass er es irgendwann aufgegeben hat. Also insofern...
Klar, wenn dein Environment halt auch einfach total......gebrochen ist...
Nee, aber wenn man ein Projekt erstmal hat, und das ist ein paar Jahre alt, und das hat keine Unit-Tests, dann sind da welche rein zu tun extrem schwierig.
Und eigentlich möchte man ja erst Unit-Tests schreiben und dann den Code schreiben.
Aber Jungs, man will nicht nur Unit-Tests schreiben, ne?
Ja, ich weiß. Das ist eine lange Diskussion, die man da führen kann.
Also ich würde ja... Also es gibt noch Functional-Tests in der Rails-Sprache. Und dann gibt's noch Integration-Tests, wo die Integration-Tests halt wirklich so von oben vom Stack einmal bis runter und wieder zurück testen. Und die Functional-Tests zumindest mal mehr als... Also ein bisschen mehr Teile vom System anfassen als nur das eine Modul und die eine Funktion. Also ich bin immer eigentlich relativ großer Fan davon, so ein bisschen mehr vom Stack zu testen, weil dann merkt man halt, wenn man mal an dem einen Rädchen wackelt, dass dann plötzlich ein anderer Teil des Systems irgendwie Probleme kriegt, was man bei den Unit-Tests halt meistens nicht hinkriegt, weil das immer nur so eine Unit-Test hat. So zum Beispiel die Adir-Funktion, ja, die wird halt immer irgendwie vielleicht korrekt... Also wenn der mal bricht, dann wär's wirklich bitter, aber weißt schon so, ne?
Also du würdest dann eher so komplexe Sachen machen, wie ruf dein eigener Feed ab oder was?
Ja, und guck, dass da die richtigen Dinge drinstehen oder... Jetzt bei unseren Spielen da bei Booger, da testet man halt auch so, ja, irgendwie, wenn der Call kommt, dann müssen da 5 Schlumpfbären mehr auf dem Konto sein, ja, und...
Der Stichpunkt ist auch Perimetertests. Also, das Ding ist ja, wenn du wirklich alle ganzen kleinen Teile testest, dann hast du irgendwann das Problem, dass du sehr inflexibel wirst, weil wenn du anfängst zu refactoren, dann berichtest du extrem viele von diesen kleinteiligen Tests. Und deswegen ist plötzlich die Lust am Refactoren so klein.
Ja, aber wenn du es halt richtig machst, dann macht Refactoren richtig Spaß, weil dann kannst du einfach mal so einen ganzen Block einfach rausreißen. Du weißt genau, wo die Tests, die fehlen und kannst so lange jetzt dann den Refactoring machen, bis wieder alles grün ist und du weißt dann halt irgendwie, ok, bin fertig. Wenn du halt wirklich diese API quasi testest von außen und nicht eben da so drin nicht festgetackert hast sozusagen.
Aber eben deswegen halt Perimetertests. Eine API ist halt eine definierte Schnittstelle. Und wenn du die definiert testest und alle Möglichkeiten, die diese Schnittstelle bietest, einmal durchtestest, dann kannst du halt auch das, was da drin passiert, einmal austauschen.
Was ist ein Perimetertest?
Naja, Perimeter im Sinn von so einem Absperrzaun rund ums Gelände. Also egal was drin ist, alles das, was rein und raus geht, testest du so, dass du irgendwie alle Möglichkeiten getestet hast. Also es ist eine Philosophie, weiß ich nicht.
Ja, es gibt halt auch so Leute, die so mit Test-Driven-Development so übertreiben, die testen dann halt Rails oder die testen den Datenbankadapter, der halt schon von Rails selber irgendwie mit mehr Tests gecovert ist, als du dir überhaupt nur vorstellen magst. Oder es wäre genauso, als würdest du ein Projekt mit WebKit machen, und würdest halt jetzt nochmal WebKit testen. Und dann verlieren die sich da so in tausenden Tests und testen eigentlich am Ende gar nicht, dass du darauf ankäme. Naja, ist so ein eigenes Thema für sich, aber ich muss sagen, nach Jahren des Test-Driven-Developments nie wieder ohne. Also es macht schon mehr Spaß. Gibt mehr Sicherheit beim mal eben Code rausreißen und neu schreiben.
Was frisst jetzt das Kurs so an Ressourcen?
Das, wie gesagt, 2 GB RAM im laufenden Prozess.
Nur das Robi oder was?
Das ist hauptsächlich das Rails und das Postgres, was da das Futtert. Aber es ist auch kein Drama, ehrlich gesagt. Ich hab einfach die Luxus-Variante genommen, hab gesagt, der kann da 10 Worker haben. Das heißt, zehnmal parallel geht das da durch, um einfach so ein bisschen die Lastspitzen abzufangen. Während zum Beispiel so einer Sendung hier, wo es gerade ein bisschen geschwächelt hat.
Ja, das ist immer ganz süß, ne?
Wenn die Leute klicken auf die Links.
Das ist immer ganz süß, wenn man dann jetzt so aus dieser Erlangen-Welt kommt. Ich muss ja auch gerade ein Ruby- und Rails-Projekt gerade wieder betreuen. Das ist wirklich immer so. Man denkt so, ist ja schon eine ganz coole Sprache und so, aber so Performance ist echt anders.
Wobei das Diskurs jetzt flott läuft, aber man muss halt so ein bisschen Blech dran werfen, damit das auch läuft. Aber dafür, also ich mach halt die Technik, bei Claudia und Ralf und Tim machen wir das Inhaltliche. So ist die Trennung ganz gut beim Sendegate.
Auf jeden Fall. Wie stark ist diese Maschine? Worauf läuft das?
Das ist so ein Hetzner aus der Serverbörse geklickt mit so einem Intel Xeon E3 mit 30 Cores und 32 GB ECC-RAM sogar noch. Und unten glaub ich eine SATA Festplatte. SATA Enterprise, irgendeine Festplatte, 10K oder so.
Das klingt ja jetzt... Noch nicht so geil, muss ich mal sagen.
Zwei Festplatten in Rake.
Könnt ihr euch da nicht was Ordentliches leisten? Dass ihr von der Hetzner Serverbörse irgendwie so ein...
Also ich finde 40 Euro für so einen Server zu bezahlen im Monat, finde ich ganz angenehm. Der funktioniert.
Und man muss den Rechner nicht kaufen.
Ich sag ja nicht Rechner kaufen, das bin ich jetzt auch nicht so der große Fan von. Also ich miete auch Server, aber Hetzner ist ja schon mal für mich so rotes Tuch. Nummer eins ist einfach einer der größten Hoster-Saftläden überhaupt. Also wirklich ganz, also Mülltonne ganz unten.
Warum?
Ja, die...
Na Festplatten?
Die machen halt billig, billig, billig. Haben null Support. Wenn du mal irgendwas vom Support willst, dann ist das so wie im Irrkanal das erste Mal aufschlagen und eine Frage stellen und dann...
Dann hast du das Topic nicht gelesen.
Also der Netzwerk-Config innerhalb des Data Centers ist komplett bogus. Der Routing ist komplett bogus. Das ist wirklich... Sowas hast du noch nicht erlebt. Du hast zwei Server am gleichen Rack, am gleichen Switch. Die haben eine Public IP, die können sich nicht gegenseitig pingen. Dann fragst du, warum? Und dann ist es so, ja, also wenn wir das erlauben würden, dann könnten ja die Leute jetzt also hier irgendwie auch die anderen Kunden und da, die den Traffic sehen und da sitzt du da so, hä, hallo, habt ihr mal irgendwie da draußen in die Welt kurz geguckt? Also andere Data Center kriegen das auch hin. Und Public IP heißt? Also auch ihr IPv6 Setup war einfach jahrelang eine absolute Katastrophe. Die bauen hier halt, wir hatten da mal eine größere Installation und irgendwie gab es da so komische Issues auf mehreren Kisten immer mal wieder. Zum Beispiel sind die einfach ausgegangen, mittendrin, ohne irgendwelche Log-Einträge stellte sie sich raus, sie haben da irgendwelche gammeligen Netzteile drin. Oder dann hat unser Admin damals, hat mal so aus Spaß einen Memorytest laufen lassen und in der einen Kiste waren halt die Hälfte der Riegel einfach Schrott. Dann hat er das auf allen Servern laufen lassen, da waren 60% der Server hatten irgendwelchen gammeligen RAM drin. Und es hat dann auch erstmal einen Monat oder so gedauert, bis sie sich dann bewegt haben und es auszutauschen. Die bauen die billigsten Netzwerkinterfaces ein, die haben wirklich nur billig, billig, billig, billig.
Na, deswegen hab ich ja zur Serverbörse gegriffen, weil da kriegst du halt diese konfigurierten Systeme, die sie irgendwie für die betuchteren Kunden machen und dann da rauf werfen, wenn sie die Kunden dann verlieren. Deswegen hab ich tatsächlich dann diesen ECC-RAM, dieser Xeon E3 und dann noch die Gigabit-Intel-Karte.
Ja, aber eine Festplatte nur?
Nee, zwei Festplatten, aber halt Software-Rate.
Was heißt aber? Ist ja gut. Also Hardware-Rate macht man ja heutzutage nicht mehr.
Selten ist es nicht mehr. Wir hatten ja mal den BitTorrent-Tracker auch bei Hetzner. Dann meinten sie irgendwie nach einer Weile, es ging natürlich nicht mehr. Dann haben wir geschrieben, was los? Meinten sie, ja hier, da wäre eine DOS-Attack. Und wir so, nee, nee, das ist schon alles korrekt. Bring it on.
Ja, aber die rauchen auch Switches ab tatsächlich.
Ja, dann haben sie gesagt, okay, haben sie es aufgeschaltet. Dann kam natürlich wirklich alles, ist der Router erst mal abgeraucht. Dann meinten sie, ja, nee, Jungs, da geht nicht so viel.
Also bei uns sind auch in der ganzen Zeit, wo ich jetzt bei VUGA bin, sind bestimmt zwei oder drei Switches im Rack bei denen abgeraucht. Dann ist halt auch die Response-Time, bis sie dann das Ding mal getauscht haben. Das ist alles immer so... Also wir haben jetzt alles da wegmigriert. Und in der Firma, ich glaube, es gibt wenig Policies, von was wir so benutzen, aber es gibt zwei Hoster, die sind auf jeden Fall auf der Blacklist. Und Hetzner ist da ganz vorne.
Und der andere?
Der heißt Veliarnet. Do Not Host bei Veliarnet ist auch ein ganz großer Saftladen. Was ist geil? Na ja, das kommt natürlich so ein bisschen drauf an. Aber zum Beispiel der eine kleine Hoster, den ich ja jetzt so für meinen Server und auch für so ein größeres Setup bei Vuga benutzt hab, der Accelerated, heißen die accelerated.net? Heiß gar nicht. So ein kleiner Hoster, ach ja genau, da fällt mir gerade noch eine geile Geschichte ein. Die find ich zum Beispiel ganz sympathisch. Die sind jetzt halt nicht so günstig wie Hetzner, aber die haben einfach einen coolen Service. Die sind sofort dabei, die kümmern sich und haben irgendwie korrektes Internet, korrekte Hardware. Das ist so ein kleinerer Hoster und dann gibt es halt natürlich die ganzen großen. Also hier, wie heißen sie? Plus-Server, sogar bei Host Europe oder so. Ich könnte mal eine Liste irgendwann ins Twitter schmeißen von den blessed Hostern, die wir benutzen. Aber eigentlich ist alles besser als, ne, nicht die, warte mal, die heißen so.
Der Club ist ja traditionsmäßig bei inter.net und da waren wir auch immer zufrieden.
Ja, schon.
In der Firma würde ich jetzt auch nicht benutzen, aber für mich reicht's. Sie benutzt ja auch Windows, ihr wisst ja.
Wir benutzen es bei VUGA nicht, ne. Wir sind bei Host Europe, bei LeaseWeb, ne, Host Europe nicht, bei LeaseWeb, Accelerated, ein paar Sachen bei Amazon, ein paar Sachen bei Plus-Server. Und ich weiß gar nicht, wo das letzte, das aktuelle, das gerade neu rauskommende Spiel oder entwickelte Spiel gehostet wird. Aber, ja. Die mag ich echt sehr gern. Also der Typ, mit dem ich da auch zu tun hatte, als wir das bei VUGA, so ein größeres Projekt hin, migriert haben von Hetzner im Übrigen, das war sehr cool. Also das sind halt nicht so Leute, weißte, es gibt so Hoste auch, da ist dann der SalesDroid, der kommt vorbei und bezahlt dir für 350 Euro ein Steak, damit du die Sachen dahin baust, aber der Service und alles andere ist einfach totaler Rotz. Und die Jungs, die sind halt total cool, die kommen auch nicht so einfach mal für irgendeinen Business-Lunch vorbei und im Anzug und mal schnacken, sondern die machen einfach. Das finde ich schonmal sympathisch. Zum Beispiel Willianet, das ist so ein Kack-Hoster, also das kann bei kleineren Hostern auch öfters passieren, dass die gar nicht ein eigenes Data Center haben, sondern sich irgendwo mit einmieten, mit so ein bisschen Racks, und dann haben die ihr Office woanders. Bei denen ist es zum Beispiel so, die haben gar kein Personal im Rechenzentrum. Das heißt, wenn du eine Festplatte tauschen willst, dann fährt einer mit seinem Publium Golf 2 irgendwie 30 Kilometer rüber ins Rechenzentrum und schraubt dann die Platte rein und das dauert halt. Du musst dann Termine machen, für wann der Mitarbeiter dann mal ins Rechenzentrum fährt. Das ist bei Hetzner besser, da läuft der Turnschuhadmin relativ schnell los, wenn man dann im Admin-Interface mal klickt. Ja genau, mach mal Hardware Reset, das geht dann schon recht fluffig, aber den braucht man halt auch öfters mal leider.
Ich hab lustigerweise mit Hetzner mit meinen Projekten nie schlechte Erfahrungen gemacht. Ich muss da die Glücksgriffe getrennt haben, aber die ganzen schlechten Erfahrungen mit Hetzner kenne ich. Die Geschichten sind alle bekannt. Und ich warte nur darauf, dass man eine meiner Festplatten demnächst einfach mal ordnungsgemäß abbraucht.
LeaseWeb muss ich sagen, das ist einer der fetten großen. Die haben einen Data Center riesengroß und haben auch irgendwie Connection ohne Ende. Es gibt ja so eine Peering-Datenbank, wo du nachgucken kannst, welche Networks wie, wo peern und was die für Bandbreiten haben. Und LeaseWeb hat, glaube ich, richtig absurd große Uplinks in allen Data Centers. Die sitzen in Amsterdam, in Frankfurt und noch irgendwo mit einem eigenen fetten Data Center. Also netztechnisch, glaube ich, sind die auf jeden Fall schon mal voll Rock-Solid. Aber da sind, sagen wir mal, die Wege, bis man mal an seine Custom-Lösung rankommt, ein bisschen härter. Wenn man nur an einen Server klicken will, super. Aber wenn man so zum Beispiel ein größeres Custom-Setup bauen will, dann ist man zum Beispiel bei kleineren Hostern mit eigenem Data Center wie Accelerated irgendwie deutlich besser dran. Weil man dann immer den kurzen Dienstweg hat und nicht irgendwie durch drei Ebenen-Tickets-Systemen durch muss. Wenn halt wirklich nur einen Server, den man klicken will, sondern den ordentlich, dann ist sowas wie LeaseWeb schon von der Stange klicken deutlich besser als Hetzen. Also die haben auch, bei denen kriegst du halt auch wirklich ganz ordentliches Internet. Die hatten schon ganz am Anfang IPv6-Prefixes for free, also bevor die anderen hier in Deutschland überhaupt noch gar nicht daran gedacht haben, das überhaupt so mit anzubieten. Die sind so für Stang-Server eigentlich voll fluffig.
Ja, mit der Ebene Download-Server ist bei Internet, wobei ich da diese Cloud benutze, da klickt man sich halt irgendwie so ein PC zusammen. Ich weiß nicht, ob es jetzt für mich irgendwie lohnen würde, so eine dedicated Maschine zu ziehen.
Ja, ich bin da halt auch immer echt mehr Fan von Hardware. Ja, also wie gesagt, dieses...
Zum Experimentieren kann man ja so anfangen, wenn es erstmal läuft, kann man ja auch was eigenes umschalten.
Genau, also das sage ich eigentlich auch immer, das machen wir auch so in der Firma, sodass wir halt schon öfters mal in der Cloud einfach ein paar Instanzen hochfahren, um mal so prinzipiell irgendwas zu testen, aber dann, wenn wir wissen, was wir brauchen, ist immer echter Hardware. Also dieser eine Punkt, der mich wirklich immer frustriert ist, wenn du in irgendeiner VM läufst, ist, dass du eben nicht gucken kannst, was ist mit der Maschine los, warum ist jetzt gerade langsam, warum ist das Netz gerade langsam, weil du immer in dieser kleinen abstrahierten Box steckst und eben nicht rausgucken kannst. Und wenn du die Kiste halt selber betreibst, dann hast du eben alle SysCTLs, alle Regler, alle Infos über das Wohlergehen der Maschine selber in der Hand. Fängt ja schon an hier bei Smart-Controls, also dass du mal gucken willst, wie dir das der Festplatte geht, wie viel Lesefehler die schon hat oder ob die schon was im Errorlock hat, das geht halt alles nicht da in der VM oder mittlerweile reichen sie vielleicht sowas auch durch, aber lange Zeit bist halt total im Blindflug. Jetzt sagt ja einer, die Preise sind bei Accelerated nicht übermäßig. Nee, die sind schon auch teurer, aber dafür kriegt man halt auch, kriegt man was. Wenig Frust. Also ich hatte bei denen zum Beispiel echt einfach noch nie irgendein Problem und ich hatte letztens wirklich eine sehr spezielle Anfragen- Ticketsystem geschrieben, dann meinte der, ja, haben jetzt gerade ein paar Kunden schon gefragt, bauen wir auch ein erstes Quartal, aber wenn du es ganz dringend brauchst, schreibe ich es dir jetzt auch von Hand mal in unseren Nameserver rein oder sowas. Da ist halt noch so ein cooler Draht. Das kriegst du halt bei den großen Providern dann wiederum auch nicht. Da bist du dann in so einem dreistufigen Ticketsystem und wenn die Features nicht schon vorne reingehen, dann ist die Chance, dass es später kommt, auch gering. Host Europe ist auch korrekt, würde ich sagen. Kann man schon machen. Ich weiß nicht, bietet Domain Factory eigentlich mittlerweile eigene Server an? Weil das ist so von den deutschen Hosts.
Wenn, dann gehören sie eh zu Host Europe.
Ach, mittlerweile echt?
Ja, Host Europe hat Domain Factory aufgekauft.
Na ja, das macht Sinn, ja. Weil Domain Factory ist tatsächlich so einer von diesen Hosts dann auch aus Deutschland gewesen, die super coolen Kundensupport hatten, also wirklich instantan, da wurde ich ja mal erkannt an der Stimme. Habe ich bei Domain Factory angerufen und dann meinte der, kann ich ihm mal eine doofe Frage stellen? Ja. Machen sie zufällig einen Podcast? Ja. Heißt dieser Podcast zufällig Mobile Max? Ja. Bist du etwa der Huckel? Nee, aber nicht nur deshalb sind die cool, sondern weil die sehr faire Preise haben und ja, auch coole Dienstleistungen. Ja, Plus-Tor, was auch host Europe mittlerweile echt krass. Die schlucken gerade alles, oder wie?
Posts, die einfach nach Download-Servern suchen, kann man vielleicht noch mal auf das Projekt Podseed verweisen. Wer da einfach nur, weil das immer so das Ding, will es irgendwie schnelle, stabile Downloads haben, die nicht wegbrechen und die vor allem so einen Run mal auch......ertragen. Also, kann ja mal sein, dass mal irgendwas populär ist oder dass einfach viele Leute irgendwas abonniert haben und man hat immer das Problem, man braucht für so einen Download-Server, Podcast-Download-Server halt immer so eine Peak-Lust. Das Ding muss irgendwie......was aushalten. Und danach......subt's meistens nur so langsam vor sich hin. Das heißt, man braucht eigentlich eine schnelle Anbindung und in meinem Fall so eine Gigabit-Verbindung absolut unerlässlich. Ich weiß noch, als ich irgendwie mal Chaos-Radio-Server auf 100 Megabit laufen hatte, das einfach gar nicht. Dann kam eine neue Sendung raus und da war dann erst mal so für vier, fünf Stunden einfach irgendwie nichts mehr. Da wurden dann so ein paar Bites rausgespült, aber so richtig gebracht hat es irgendwie nichts. Ich muss gerade mal gucken, wo meine Peaks eigentlich gerade sind. Clemens hat mir ja da so ein Observium eingerichtet, womit ich zumindest mal gucken kann, wie es so aussieht. Nicht, dass ich da jetzt besonders viel dran feststellen kann.
Achso, übrigens noch eine Sache, die ich hier in den Chat posten wollte, die Peering-DB. Da kann man zumindest, vielleicht hat Clemens da auch noch eine viel geilere URL, da kann man so für die ganzen Networks mal gucken, wie die so gepieert sind und irgendwie LeaseWeb hat irgendwie am Amsics alleine 6-10 Gigabit ab links, also die sind schon echt fett dabei. Nee, sogar mehr, 100 Gigabit, was? Ja, musst du da Guest reinschreiben, wie es da unten steht, im Kleingedruckten, dann kannst du da Network suchen.
Ich guck grad mal hier, aber es ist grad nicht so aussagekräftig. Also hier wird mir so ein Peak von 450 Megabit als Auskunft gegeben.
Ja, ich hab irgendwie heute Mittag auch in eine neue Folge 300 Hertz rausgeschoben wurde. In Spitzenzeit mit 40 Megabyte die Sekunde gezogen. Aber es sind diese ganzen komischen Networks und Verteilmeter Podcast-Portale, die das wahrscheinlich dann so einmal mit Wire-Speed kurz ansaugen. Die 100 Megabyte.
Wo kommt denn deine Podcast-Dateien her?
Na, von meinem Server.
Ja, der dann pulligt.
Frankfurt?
Also du hast da irgendwie so einen dedicated Server, da hast du einen FreeBase-Stil drauf und in so einem Jail läuft dann dein Download-Server sozusagen. Und auf einem anderen Jail läuft dann der Rest.
Ja, also...
Auch der Podcast-Kram.
Naja, ne, das 300 Hertz ist so ein... Ja, ne, da fluppt das aber alles her. Aber ja, kaum drückst du halt da Publish, da rattert dann irgendwie das schon krass hoch. Und ich vermute ja, das sind diese ganzen Podcast-Networks. Und jeder Podcast-Klein hat auch mittlerweile sein eigenes...
CDN-Datei.
Und die ziehen das auch alles dann da wahrscheinlich einmal fett runter und dann sieht der Download total mega krass aus und in Wirklichkeit hört's gar keiner.
Im Chat wird noch gefragt, ob du eine Meinung zu Digital Ocean hast.
Hab ich nicht.
Ich mag die ja. Die bieten halt so auch virtuelle Kisten mit SSDs halt vor allem. Also nur mit SSDs. 5 Dollar, kleine Kisten, wenn man einigermaßen ein paar Dinge machen kann. Und die haben halt auch jetzt so eine Partnerschaft mit dem Core OS gemacht, um die Stalker nochmal zu promoten.
Und sie haben glaube ich, das waren noch die, die FreeBSD zum Laufen gekriegt haben.
Genau, die haben das jetzt auch mit FreeBSD.
Ja, also insofern prinzipiell sind die mir nicht unsympathisch, aber ich hab sie noch nicht benutzt, deswegen kann ich da jetzt keine Empfehlungen zu geben. Also ich bin halt seit E und J irgendwie schon eher auf dedicated Hardware unterliegen. Ich hatte noch, also ich hatte mal tatsächlich so ein bisschen VM-Fu getestet, das war tatsächlich von Domain Factory damals, war aber auch nur so zum Testen und entweder war ich bei anderen Freunden auf dem Server und hab ein Jail gehabt, was dann im Prinzip ja auch dedicated Server schon sehr nahe kommt, weil der First Level Support im Jobber online ist und man fragen kann, was da jetzt gerade auf dem Server los ist oder halt selber in der Kiste geklickt. Also ich zahle mir meinen Server tatsächlich auch mit noch jemand anderem, der den aber so gut wie nicht benutzt, deswegen zahle ich auch nur die Hälfte der Hosting-Kosten. So eine kleine Server-WG, das kann ich euch auch empfehlen, wenn ihr ein bisschen spielen wollt, klickt euch halt einen Server zu zweit oder zu dritt oder zu viert und dann kriegt ihr dann Jail.
Der noch wie Milliarden von Spams an seinem Fold hat.
Nee, also ich bin auch lieber allein auf dem Server. Also die Hoster, die sind mittlerweile alle mit V6 am Start. Sogar Hetzen hat es ja geschafft seit, ich glaube die waren aber relativ spät dran und die haben ja auch lange gebraucht, um ihr IPv6-Setup gerade zu kriegen. Aber bei den Hostern kriegst du eigentlich immer so einen V6-Prefix mittlerweile nachgeworfen, schon seit Jahren.
Nur bei den ganz großen nicht.
Wie? Welche ganz großen?
Luljuri meint hier gerade Windows...
Amazon hat auch lange keinen V6 angeboten. Ich weiß nicht, ob es das mittlerweilige Ton immer noch nicht. Ja gut, aber das ist dann halt Cloud. Cloud hat noch keine V6.
Ja, bzw. sie haben wahrscheinlich einfach genug IPv4-Adressen, als dass es sie erst mal noch nicht interessiert, oder?
Ja, aber sehr zusammengestückelt leider.
Ja, naja gut, aber ich meine, wenn die mal auf V6 umstellen, dann ist aber auch wirklich... dann brummt es dann im Netz.
Ja, wobei, dann müssen ja erstmal die ganzen Leute, die jetzt da schon VMS betreiben, müssen ja dann auch in ihrer Software mal das Flag anschalten, dass sie jetzt auch bitte V6 benutzen wollen. Das passiert ja nicht automatisch, nur weil das da am Link anliegt. Also da muss der DNS-Records im Zweifel mal noch setzen und so.
Na klar.
Aber ja, eigentlich ist eine gute Frage, warum zum Beispiel Amazon das immer noch nicht...
Also das Internet sagt, oder Google sagt, dass Amazon IPv6 hat.
Mir wär nämlich eigentlich auch so gewesen, als hätten sie das.
Welcher Teil von Amazon?
EC2 und der Load-Balancer davor.
Ja, das ist aber glaub ich auch alles, was...
Ja, das ist ja schon mal...
Ob S3 v6 hat, weiß ich jetzt gar nicht.
Das wär mir neu.
Aber immerhin EC2. Und das hat glaub ich aber auch eine ganze Weile gedauert. Also da waren sie auch relativ spät dran. Naja, aber... Ja, also da wird auch mittlerweile überhaupt gar nicht mehr irgendein Bohai gemacht. Also bei Hetzner kannst du da glaub ich einfach eine Checkbox mittlerweile anchecken, dass du gerne einen Prefix hättest.
Oder mittler.
Das war bei den anderen auch alles so. Kann man schon mal machen.
Was passt denn jetzt hier noch ganz gut rein? Dennis meint...
3BSD 10.1.
In die Sendung reinholen. Na, äh, nachdem ich... Nachdem ich meine Bitcoin-Gröten von Mount Gox nicht schon wegbekommen habe, dachte ich mir so, jetzt mach ich mal Bitstamp und dann sind die dann irgendwie auch down.
Die sind aber wieder da.
Ja, sind wieder da. Meinen wir auch.
Aber das hatten wir doch in der letzten Sendung schon, das Thema. Genau.
Ja, aber da war noch nicht klar, dass die auch wirklich jetzt welche... Also wie viel sie verloren haben.
Na, fünfeinhalb Millionen Dollar hatten sie damals gesagt.
Fünfeinhalb Millionen Dollar?
Ja, zu dem damaligen Kurs. Ist ja billiger geworden jetzt für dieses Problem.
Ja, die haben sich irgendwie 19.000 Bitcoins klauen lassen. Aber hast du mitbekommen, wie?
Ich bin ja bei denen nicht. Ich hab's mit den Exchanges nicht, fass die nicht mehr an. Viel zu heiß, sieht man ja.
Ja.
Können's alle nicht.
Ja, die haben ja irgendwie gewarnt, dass...
Dass man auf diese Adressen da irgendwie nicht mehr einzahlen soll. Also sie wussten nicht, wer da bei denen rumgefuscht hat und wer nicht.
Ja, aber zumindest haben sie sich so weit abgesichert, dass sie da ihre, also die Bitcoins, die man dort gelagert hat, in, wie sagen sie das schön, im Cold Storage haben.
Ja, ich glaube, ein Kollege, der da auch einige Bitcoins hatte und sich damit beschäftigt hat, der hat mir erzählt, das habe ich aber noch nicht überprüft, dass sie tatsächlich auch so Paper Wallets da so quasi im Ordner betreiben, so dass das auch gar nicht so mit Computern irgendwie in Berührung kommt an der Stelle. Aber ob das jetzt wirklich stimmt, weiß ich nicht, das hat mir nur der Kollege berichtet.
Meinst du, das drucken die aus und scannen das dann wieder ein?
So war die Sache. Also er meinte, sie hätten...
Wenn sie schlau sind, dann machen die das so.
Ja, also sie meinten, er meinte, er hätte bei denen auf der Seite das irgendwie so gelesen.
Solange sie das nicht mit den Scannern von Xerox machen, die die Zahlen tauschen.
UR-Codes.
Ja, naja, aber Bitcoin ist ja irgendwie auch gerade ein bisschen nicht so viel wert.
186 müsste es sein.
189 Euro sehe ich hier gerade.
Und man muss jetzt aber noch dazu sagen, da der Euro gerade so schwach ist, also sagen wir so, wenn sich der Bitcoin-Kurs nicht verändert hätte, dann in Euro, dann würde er schon leicht ansteigen, allein dadurch, dass der Euro gegenüber dem Dollar schwächer ist. Und das muss man da auch noch mit einbeziehen. So gesehen ist der eigentlich jetzt noch mal ein paar Euro weiter unten, wenn man das mit reinrechnen würde.
Na ja, das war ja hier einer der nächstgrößere Market, der jetzt erst mal wieder ein Problem hat. Hat wieder das Vertrauen geschwächt.
Der ist ganz, also die Dinger, die da weggekommen sind, das ist nicht so groß. Da gibt es viel größere Exchanges. Und die Anzahl der Transaktionen im letzten Jahr hat sich auch verdoppelt gegenüber dem Jahr davor. Also das alles sieht ganz super aus. Microsoft unterstützt Bitcoins und so weiter. Also eigentlich ist alles ganz okay. Ich glaube auch eher, da sind irgendwie Leute, die jetzt hier dick abstoßen und mal kassieren wollten oder irgendwie so. Anders kann ich es mir nicht vorstellen.
Tarif?
Leute, die irgendwie 2009 angefangen haben, wenn die da so ein paar 100.000 Bitcoins haben oder 50 oder 10.000, dann ist denen das auch egal. Ob es aber auch wirklich daran liegt, also wenn es einer wissen würde, da gibt es tausend Theorien und jeder erzählt ja irgendwie was anderes. Einer meinte, dass die Butterfly Labs, das ist eine der bekanntesten Buden, die am Anfang viel mit FPGAs und Asics später umgespielt haben, die aber, na ja, ein Scam ist es nicht, weil sie haben die Geräte ja tatsächlich ausgeliefert, aber die haben tatsächlich von einer amerikanischen Finanzbehörde eins auf den Deckel bekommen und müssen jetzt allen Leuten, die irgendwie da bestellt haben und denen sie noch nicht geliefert haben, also noch nicht, weil die liefern ja immer irgendwann, denen müssen sie jetzt irgendwie das Geld zurückgeben, und zwar auch in der Währung, in der sie bezahlt haben. Und bei denen haben immer viele Leute den Bitcoins bezahlt. Und sie meinen, dass Butterfly Labs hatte sein ganzes Geld wo irgendwie ein Bitcoin ist und die zahlen gerade davon aus und das schwemmt gerade den Markt. Aber da haben auch schon viele Leute gesagt, ja, nee, das ist auch blöd. Das wäre auch viel zu wenig, als dass das irgendwie so eine Preisänderung da machen würde. Aber wenn keiner sieht, woher die kommt und da aber eine ist, dann ist auch so ein bisschen unklar. Also irgendwie ist es auch der Bitcoin-Markt so kleiner im Verhältnis zum Aktienmarkt auch ist. Da blickt auch schon keiner durch, warum, wie da die Preise sinken, fallen und überhaupt. Also es ist alles komplex.
Allerdings, das kann man so festhalten.
Du bist leider nicht der Warren Buffett des Bitcoins.
Nee, ich bin...
Warum nicht?
Ja, zu spät eingestiegen.
Also so richtig spät warst du ja nicht.
Also ich wollte auch sagen, von allen Leuten, die ich so kenne und die mit Bitcoin was zu tun haben, da warst du schon ganz schön weit vorne mit dabei.
Ich kenne jetzt auch nicht direkt einen, der da vorher bei war, außer jetzt so ein paar Jungs bei Room 77, aber sonst wüsste ich jetzt nicht. Aber zu spät. 2010 wäre, glaube ich, so das günstige Jahr gewesen. Oder ein paar Monate früher in 2011. Aber kann man ja alles nicht wissen. Aber um es nochmal hier klar zu sagen als Aussage, ich bin weit an der Meinung, Long-Term Investing, dann muss man durch.
Einfach halten.
Ja, so wie bei Apple. Die hatten ja diesen Riesenaufschwung vor zwei Jahren. Genau, vor zwei Jahren war das. Da sind die doch so mega krass eingebrochen. Und dann dachten auch viele, ja, klar, der Peak ist vorbei. Der war ja dann schon 2013, muss er gewesen sein. So in Oktober oder so. Das war jetzt der Peak, jetzt geht es wieder abwärts. Kurzes Tal und Vosenze gerade. Wahrscheinlich werden sie wieder auch in einer Woche, glaube ich, den nächsten Quartalzahlen wieder mal Best Quarter Ever vorstellen. Und der Kurs rockt auch gerade alles, was geht. Also, ja.
Welches Quartal stellen sie jetzt vor? Das Weihnachten-Ding, ne?
Das wird knallen. Der Kurs geht gerade schon hoch, weil irgendwie wohl alle der Meinung sind, dass sie doch noch mehr abgesetzt haben als irgendwie predicted. Wie auch immer die das so predigten können, ist mir echt nicht so klar, weil die gucken tatsächlich in die Zukunft. Also klar, die kennen natürlich ihre Bestellungen und so weiter, aber trotzdem müssen doch schon, wenn sie ihr neues Phone rausbringen, müssen die doch irgendwie so einen Weihnachtsquartal einschätzen, wie viele Leute kaufen das jetzt und wie viele nicht. Und die treffen das schon immer ziemlich gut. Also mir ist nicht so klar, wie die das machen.
Ich hab mal so ein bisschen in die Vergangenheit geschaut. Ich hatte ja hier das Problem, dass meine HFS-Datalsysteme im Eimer sind. Und ich konnte mich bisher noch nicht dazu durchringen, das einfach mal platt zu machen. Ich dachte mir, das muss doch irgendwie zu machen sein. Und früher habe ich ja dann immer meinen DiskWarrior genommen.
Der gute alte.
Der gute alte DiskWarrior. Das ist irgendwie auch so eine merkwürdige Bude. Also es gibt da diesen Laden Allsoft. Die haben irgendwie das letzte Mal ein Update gemacht für diesen DiskWarrior. Keine Ahnung, fünf, sechs Jahre her. Das war einfach uralte MacOS-Hardware. Ja, immer. Aber auf jeden Fall nicht so richtig immer, immer.
Immer nicht. Früher gab es ja FWD Tool Disk oder wie ist das Ding?
DiskWarrior ist schon lange dabei.
Jaja, ist schon lange dabei. Aber unser lange ist schon ganz schön lange.
Ihr habt den längsten.
Ja, also es war irgendwann auch mal neu. Und ja, irgendwie kam da nichts mehr. Und zu meiner größten Überraschung hieß es vor ein paar Tagen, ja, hier, uns gibt es noch und übrigens, wir haben jetzt mal eine neue Version rausgebracht.
Zu unserer Überraschung ist HFS immer noch nicht tot. Und wir dachten ja schon, wir können jetzt endlich mal in Rente gehen. Aber nein, irgendwie Apple gönnt uns, noch eine Version rauszubringen. Jetzt haben wir es.
Genau. Und ich hatte halt hier so einen Rate in meinem Mac Pro, wo das OS X nur noch meinte, da sind wohl irgendwie Daten, aber ich kann da jetzt nicht so mit klagen. Also ich kann dir das zwar auch noch anzeigen, aber schreiben wäre jetzt dann doch ein bisschen vermessen und geht irgendwie gar nicht. Wenn man auf diese Althoff-Webseite kommt, da hat man auch noch so ein bisschen das Gefühl der Vergangenheit.
So ein 10-1-10-2-Flashback.
Ja genau, also die Jungs, die sind auch...
Oder wie hieß das? Mac OS X Server 1.0? So ungefähr sieht das aus.
Ist total oldschool und wie auch immer, ich hab mir gedacht so, scheiß drauf, ich kauf mir das jetzt einfach. Auch nicht irgendwie jetzt hier in irgendwelchen Tauschbörsen rumgelungen und mal geguckt, ob da ein Torrent ist oder so und nix, sondern ich hab's mir einfach geschoppt.
Was kostet dieser Tage?
19 Dollar Vollversion.
Ja, ich dachte mir halt so...
Naja, also ich muss sagen, ich hab vielleicht in meinem Mac-Leben dreimal DiskWarrior gebraucht und dreimal hat DiskWarrior geliefert. Also es war zumindest so, wenn ich jetzt nochmal so in so einer Lage wäre und ich müsste jetzt mal dringend, bevor ich dann den WIG anrufe, würde ich vielleicht auch nochmal...
Es hat bei mir immer geliefert. Das fand ich wirklich krass. Also was auch kaputt war, DiskWarrior kommt daher. Und man muss mal kurz erklären. Also das Problem ist ja, HFS+, das Datalsystem vom Mac, ist wirklich alt. Also wirklich, wirklich, wirklich alt. Also nicht nur, dass es das schon lange gibt, sondern es ist auch konzeptionell einfach alt. Wir haben das ja auch schon x-mal thematisiert, bzw. wir haben vor allem viel über ZFS geredet, und was ZFS alles so richtig macht.
Das heißt, wenn wir jetzt so richtig Fanboys sind, dann sagen wir, das ist so alt, das ist so geil abgehangen und so Rock'n'Roll-Stable?
Was jetzt?
Naja, so könnte man es ja jetzt machen.
Die letzte Colonel Panic wegen dem Datalsystem ist eine Weile her.
Also es gab schlimmere Zeiten, auf jeden Fall. Wir wissen, dass das On-Disc-Format, also die Daten, die halt wirklich auf der Platte stehen, die sind halt nicht sonderlich resilient. Also es ist so, wenn da so die kosmische Strahlung durch die Platten durchzieht und die Bits umklappen, dann klappen die halt auch einfach um und mangels Check-Zooming und ähnlichen Methoden. Ist es nicht nur kaputt, sondern die Software merkt es halt auch erstmal nicht. Also schon gar nicht sofort, aber eben auch später nicht. Und die Annahmen darüber, was dann da falsch ist, sind auch unklar. Und diese ganzen Bordmittel, diese ganzen, ja, hier Disk Utility, Repair My Disk, Buttons, etc., die schauen sich das so kurz ein und dann so, ah, nee, ja, nee. Das sind so wirklich diese totalen Experten. Dann hast du ein Problem, dann ruft es dir irgenso einen an, dann kommt er in seinen weißen Kittel und sagt, ja, ist gar kein Problem. Und dann schaut er sich irgendwie die Leiche an und dann so, ah, nee, ist eigentlich doch nicht ganz so mein Bereich. Incoming DiskWarrior. Und das interessante an DiskWarrior ist, dass die schon immer einen anderen Film gefahren haben. Die gehen da einfach anders ran. Was die nämlich machen, ist, sie scannen erstmal die ganze Platte und sie haben da so einen 10-stufigen Prozess, den sie da durchlaufen. Lesen erstmal, was sie lesen können, schauen, wo irgendwelche Informationen noch sind. Also in der Regel ist ja auch nicht unbedingt alles komplett im Eimer. Die verzeichneten Strukturen haben halt so Fehler. Und da fehlt dann hier mal ein Bit und dann ist da mal was falsch gesetzt. Und dann ist irgendwie was nicht da. Dann scannen sie einfach die ganze Platte ab und suchen auch nach den ganzen Doubletten. Und fangen aber nicht gleich an, wie so Norton Disk Doctor oder ähnliche Vögel lustig drauf loszuschreiben oder wie auch das normale Disk Utility und irgendwas zu reparieren. Sondern sie bauen erstmal ein komplett neues Verzeichnis auf im RAM. Und ich hab das jetzt hier gemacht mit meinem neuen Terabyte RAID. Wo mal, keine Ahnung, ich hab dann die finale Zahl mir nicht angeschaut. Muss mal gucken, ob ich den Result hier noch irgendwo hingeschrieben habe. Hier ist der Report. Da generiert der einen dann so ein mehrseitiges PDF.
13 Millionen Files.
Da waren wir so 13 Millionen, 13,8 Millionen.
Immerhin noch 800 Gig frei.
Genau. Und so 17 Milliarden Dissektoren. Und das Ganze irgendwie als Rate. Und das war jetzt schon so...
Und Blogsize schon auf 16 Kilobyte hoch.
Boah, ein Stripe.
Genau. Und dann hat er irgendwie hier mal 287 Millionen Vergleichstests durchgeführt. So als Ergebnis. Und liefert einem so eine ewige Liste, wo, was weiß ich, welche Flex da einfach falsch waren. Das sind meistens harmlose Sachen, irgendwelche Custom-Icon-Flex, die nicht gesetzt sind, aber eben auch teilweise ein bisschen kniffligere Sachen. Hab ich mir jetzt am Einzelnen nicht durchgelesen. Auf jeden Fall, er baut erst mal ein komplett neues Verzeichnis auf. Das heißt, er ändert irgendwie kein Bit auf der ganzen Platte, sondern er baut im RAM ein neues, eine neue Disk, quasi eine Verzeichnisstruktur auf und mounted die virtuell. Und dann kann man da erst mal drauf rumklicken. Das heißt, man hat quasi nur einen anderen View auf dieselben Daten, ohne dass irgendein Bit auf der Platte geändert wird. Dann kann man sich das alles in Ruhe anschauen. Dann kann man im Prinzip auch von da schon alles wegkopieren. Und wenn man so einem feeling lucky mäßig drauf ist, dann kann man einfach sagen, schreib mir jetzt mal das Verzeichnis auf die Platte. Und dann nimmt er halt diese neue, frisch aufgebaute Struktur und schreibt die einfach an anderen Stellen weg. Also fast halt möglichst nichts an, was irgendwie kaputt gehen kann, sondern schreibt es woanders hin, weil wo die Verzeichnisinformationen stehen, das steht am Ende auch nur in irgendeinem Masterblock und das war's. Ja, und das hab ich dann einfach mal gemacht. Replace, Return.
Vielleicht hat es noch mal 8TB Platz irgendwo.
Na, er hat das auf derselben Platte dann hingeschrieben. Also er hat das alte Verzeichnis, das kaputte Verzeichnis durch ein komplett neues Verzeichnis ersetzt.
Die Daten dagelassen, wo sie sind, und nur den Verzeichnisbaum neu gepinselt.
Ja, und wo vorher mein Time Machine immer meinte so, nee, fass ich nie an, riecht schlecht. Meinte der danach, ach, da bist du ja wieder. Dann kann ich ja hier weiter mit meinem Backup. Das war einfach so die Experience. Man nimmt tote, kaputtes HFS-Filesystem, was einfach sein Leben ausgehauchst hat.
Du hast jetzt ein gutes Gefühl.
Ja.
Naja, mit dem DiskWarrior in der Seite kann man das HFS jetzt irgendwie machen.
Und da hast du immerhin ein mittleres Gefühl.
So ein paar Beweise, so ein paar Dateien so gechecksummt oder so? Oder so ein paar Diskimages, die sich selber checksummen, die noch okay sind und sich mounten lassen? Also woher weißt du jetzt, ob das okay ist?
Ja, Wissen ist ja relativ. Man muss ja Vertrauen haben.
Wie bei den Bitcoins.
Ist mehr so ein Long-Term-Investment.
Feeling lucky, also es ist halt Time Machine kam vorher halt nicht klar und fing dann auch gleich an weiter fleißig da zu sein.
Verstehe, und das Disk Utility Tool, das Disk Utility...
Ja, das kannst du in der Pfeife rauchen meistens.
Also bei mir, da gibt's immer so ein paar Sachen und dann ist es meistens wieder gut.
Ja, nee, der Satz einfach geht gar nix.
Also ich hatte wirklich drei, wenn ich mich recht entsinne, so Inzidenz, wo auch entweder das ganze Fallsystem im Arsch war oder Teile davon irgendwie in einem echt jiggy-State und ich hab dann auch DiskWarrior mal da drauf losgelassen, hinterher war alles wieder gut. Wobei ich glaube ich in dem einen Fall das dann auf eine neue Platte sozusagen gerettet habe. Ja, aber ja, ich kann auch nur sagen, in drei von drei Fällen hat das Tool, ich war auch ähnlich skeptisch, weil ich das letzte Mal das probiert hab, da sah das auch sehr angestaubt aus, also die vorherige Version, die sah ähnlich angestaubt aus, wie jetzt wahrscheinlich die neue im Vergleich zu der anderen Software, aber ja, es tut. Erstaunlicherweise tat es. Oder was heißt erstaunlicherweise? Ich hatte halt irgendwie so ein bisschen Skizze, weil ich dachte, okay, ist jetzt irgendwie so eine Bude, die im letzten Jahrtausend stecken geblieben ist, softwaremäßig, aber was sie wissen, wird man mit HFS machen muss.
Also, wenn ihr eine Platte habt und das Betriebssystem meint, kann ich nicht mehr mounten, kann ich nichts mit anfangen, weiß ich nicht, kann ich nicht drauf schreiben, etc. Und euch sind die Daten auch nur irgendwas wert, dann könnt ihr einfach DiskWarrior kaufen. Sag ich jetzt mal so.
Also die Daten sind euch mehr als 119 Dollar wert.
Und es gibt eine ganze Menge Daten, die einem mehr als 119 Dollar wert sein sollten. Ja, dazu meine Empfehlung, Allsoft DiskWarrior 5.
Rufen sie jetzt die Nummer neben ihrer Landesflagge an.
Genau.
Oder klicken sie aufs PayPal-Icon.
Wenn wir gerade schon bei Filesystems sind, dann will ich jetzt meine Hardware-Ecke reinschmeißen. Das passt nämlich, glaube ich, so ein bisschen.
Deine Hardware-Ecke möchtest du reinschmeißen?
Ja, jetzt muss ich so ein bisschen wiederholen, aber stehen die Leute vielleicht drauf, hoffe ich. Und zwar kurzer Abriss nochmal. Ich hab ja einen Mac Pro. Ich wollte eine schnellere Platte oder besser gesagt, ich wollte keine Platte mehr, sondern eine SSD. Aber Standardproblem ist, der Mac Pro hat nur SATA 2. Inzwischen gibt es SATA 3. Könnte man sich jetzt eine Karte kaufen, die mit einem PCI-Slot stecken und sich eine SATA 3 SSD kaufen. Aber dann hätte man wieder auch keinen Trim, weil es nicht von Apple und so weiter und so fort. Und vor allem wäre es auch mit SATA 3 nur maximal so 550 MB die Sekunde schnell. Und da kennen wir ja von Apple besseres als den letzten Macbook Pros. Hat ja einer von euch so ein Ding? Nee, so 2013 oder neuer? Ende 2013, genau.
Mit 2013 habe ich auch.
Ihr habt da SSDs drin, so eine flachen Blade-Module, die kommen wohl von Samsung. Das heißt M2 oder SATA M2 oder M2 SATA weiß ich gar nicht. Und ist verdammt schnell, weil es eben nicht mehr über so Kabel geht wie bei SATA 3, 2 oder 1, sondern es ist halt direkt mit zum Adapter oder mit zum Stecker auf der Platine, auf dem Board. Und das ist schön schnell. Aber weil Apple natürlich nicht will, dass ihr von Samsung euch Upgrades kaufen könnt, haben die den Hardware-Stecker geändert. Der ist leicht anders. Das heißt, sie sprechen das gleiche Protokoll, aber die Pins sind irgendwie so ein bisschen gejuggelt oder wie sagt man, durcheinander gewürfelt. Und deswegen kann man, könnt ihr keine einfach so von Samsung billige SSD-Module kaufen, sondern nur von Apple. Und Apple verkauft eigentlich, glaube ich, auch gar keine direkt, nur wenn eure kaputt sind und ihr den alten abgibt. Egal. Jedenfalls diese Module, die ihr da drin habt, die sind zwar nicht kompatibel mit der Welt da draußen, aber die Chinesen sind ja nicht so schlecht. Die bauen die passenden Adapter und die kann man sich kaufen für 10 Dollar. Gibt's von Sintek. Ich habe jetzt leider bei eBay keinen gefunden, aber die gibt's. Das heißt, man kann eure SSD-Module von Apple Ende 2013 oder später für Mac Pro kann man sich kaufen. 512 Gig für, ich habe mit Zoll irgendwie 450 Euro bezahlt. Man kauft 10 Dollar diesen Adapter, steckt den in seinen Mac Pro und hat dann erstens irgendwie, ich habe jetzt nur, weil ich habe nur 512 und nicht einen Terabyte, so 600, 700 Megabyte die Sekunde, kann davon booten. Und weil es eine Apple SSD ist, habe ich auch einen nativen Trim-Support und muss da nicht diesen Trim-Enabler benutzen, der bis 10.9. ja ganz okay war, aber seit 10.10. ist jetzt blöd, weil man muss jetzt ein ganzes Kernel Extensions Signing irgendwie ausschalten, damit der Trim-Enabler-Hack irgendwie funktioniert. Und das finde ich ja dann doch ein bisschen blöd eigentlich. Jedenfalls habe ich das alles gemacht, weil das Modul hatte ich schon seit einem Monat zu Hause rumliegen, aber der Adapter kam halt aus China und die brauchten halt ewig, weil nur 10 Dollar, also inklusive Shipping, kam heute, habe ich alles gemacht und reingeschmissen und installiert und rübergeschoben und rockt wie nichts. Und dann der blöde Apple Installer ist natürlich nicht ganz so schlau und sagt mir beim Initialisieren, ey, hier willst du auch gleich Krypto machen. Nee, sagt natürlich erst, wenn du fertig bist, wenn schon alles voll ist an Daten, weil dann dauert es ja nochmal extra lange, er hätte das gleich gemacht, dann wäre es ja in einem Rutsch gegangen, hat er aber nicht gemacht. Na gut, jedenfalls flutzt das. Also wenn man native Nativbooten in MidTrim Enable irgendwie in schnell haben will, dann irgendwie bei eBay Apple SSDs für ein Mac Pro, also für die runde Tonne irgendwie sich besorgen, dann von Sintek so ein Adapter und nicht den falschen von D-Log, weil das ist der für den normalen Samsung-Module, die dem Standard entsprechen, sondern ihr müsst den kaufen, der für die Apple-Module ist, die ein bisschen anders aussehen und dann flotscht das alles.
Aber wenn Apple das SSD nicht verkauft wird, dann?
Da gibt es doch Leute, die verkaufen dir das. Also einer, der heißt, hat irgendwie Sputnik mit im Namen, auch bei eBay, da hab ich aber vorhin geguckt, der hat gerade keine da für das, was ich mache, der hat für 2012er Macs da, die kann man dann aber wahrscheinlich auch wirklich nur einen Mac benutzen, aber da sind immer mal wieder, man muss da nach Apple, Samsung und SSD suchen und dann kommen da so eine Teile, da muss man die Texte aber genau lesen, es muss wirklich Ende 2013 oder später sein und vor allem diese runde Tonne von Mac Pro unterstützen und dann kann man das mit einem Adapter in seinen alten Mac Pro bauen und dann geht's ab.
Ja, also wirklich, der steht ja auf dem Schreibtisch von einem Kollegen zwei Meter weiter. Ja, mir ist es schon öfters passiert tatsächlich, dass ich mich so umdrehe und im Augenwinkel denke, warum hat der ein Papierkörper auf dem Schreibtisch stehen. Also wirklich ohne Scheiß und dann gucke ich genau, ah, nee, ist der Mac. Ist mir wirklich ehrlich schon zwei, dreimal passiert.
Ja, also ich bin der Meinung, dieser Mac Pro, der alte, der Classic Mac Pro, der wird so was als das Gerät in die Geschichte eingehen, weil der wird so gepimpt an allen Ecken und Enden gerade, der wird's noch ein paar Jahre machen, glaube ich.
Der erfährt viel Liebe.
Auf jeden Fall und die geben sich da echt Mühe. Also ich würde mich nicht mal wundern, wenn sie demnächst, der eine hat schon nachgefragt, wie es aussieht, er will da so irgendwelche Intel-CPUs reinbauen, die aber, wo halt es keine Firmware gibt, also keine neuen Intel-CPUs, weil die passen natürlich nicht, sondern auch schon ältere, aber die halt irgendwie trotzdem keinen Support in der Firmware haben und dann meinen sie, ja da müssten wir den Microcode hier von dort, von dem Frey Mac nehmen und das Stück da raus extrahieren und dann da irgendwie an die Stelle kleben, wo wir über den anderen rüber, weil die anderen CPUs willst ja sowieso nicht haben, klatschen wir das einfach da so rüber und ich hab da auch schonmal geguckt und bin schon dabei, weil ich mache im Studium hier Folgendes. My Mac? Ja wirklich, also ich finde es, also Mac-Rumors, da geht es echt ab und bei das andere Forum ist netcast.org, da quatscht immer über so ein Zeug und klar, da ist eine Menge, eine Menge Rauschen, aber da manchmal sind da auch echt so ein paar Körschen drunter und dann macht es echt Spaß, was die da so anstecken.
Unter den ganzen Streuseln sind dann auch manchmal ein paar längere Körschen.
Nee, nee, Streuseln ist ja das allerbeste. Ich bin ja ein Streuselfan, deswegen, das kann man so nicht sagen.
Wieder ein Stück, jetzt konnten die Fans gerade wieder dem, Dennis, wieder ein kleines Stück näher kommen, den Dennis mit einem N, ihr wisst also, wie ihr ihm eine Freude machen könnt auf dem nächsten Kongress.
Streuselkuchen, aber der muss wirklich gut sein.
Mit mehr Streusel als Kuchen. Und was haben wir jetzt davon?
Nix, aber Leute, die halt einen Mac Pro haben, also das sind halt hauptsächlich Leute, die Videoschnitt machen, brauchen richtig schnell Platte. Die brauchen sowas und die haben halt teilweise, der neue Mac Pro ist zwar geil, aber so, da Platten extern und so, Thunderbolt ist halt teuer und dann ist es vielleicht auch schnell, aber ist halt vor allem teuer. Und wenn die noch so einen alten Mac Pro haben, der hat halt nur SATA 2, das ist halt nicht schnell und diese Adapterkarten, dann hast du SATA 3, aber richtig schnell ist halt, da gibts Leute, die haben sich jetzt diese Samsung 1 TB Apple SSD gekauft und die macht halt 1,4 GB die Sekunde und das willst du halt haben, eigentlich. Ich hab jetzt leider nicht die mit 1 TB gekauft.
Also richtig viel billiger geworden sind die SSDs nicht, ne? Ich hab grad mal geschaut, ich hab mir vor zwei Jahren, hab ich mir hier so ein, was war das? Kostet, glaub ich, die 500 da, war so bei 280 Euro. Jetzt hier so bei 200 Euro dasselbe Modell, kann das sein?
Kann sein, ich hab vor Mai 2011, ist der von 2011? Ja, Mai 2011 hab ich, glaub ich, 500 Euro für eine 250 GB SSD bezahlt. Also so gesehen, jetzt kriegste 500 GB für 250 Euro. Also viermal billiger anzwischen, passt doch.
Hab ich mich verrechnet?
Ja, weiß nicht, kann sein.
Na was kauft man denn derzeit?
Kommt drauf an, was du haben willst für eine SSD. Ich kann das genau sagen.
Wenn ich jetzt mal von den normalen...
2,5 Zoll SATA 3 Anschluss, ja? Da kauft man sich eine Samsung 850 EVO Pro. Und das ist so das rechts unten. Also wenn SSDs dann, glaub ich, ist...
Die Pro...
Ach so, und EVO ist auch nur so ein Zusatz. Okay, dann gibt's eine 850 Pro und eine 850 EVO. Ich würde mal sagen, die sind beide ziemlich gut. Also wenn man es halt richtig rechts unten haben will, nimmt man die Pro, wenn nicht dann die EVO.
Also die 1 TB kostet 400 Euro gerade.
Das sind 40 Cent pro GIGABYTE, sagt man das so?
Ach die ist gerade jetzt billiger in diesem Moment? Oder was? Nur noch ein Stück am Lager?
Bei Amazon, ja. Jetzt bestellen. Die Agenten haben jetzt gleich den Preis gesenkt, weil sie sagen, Uwe, jetzt komm!
Jetzt kommt die My Mac-Sektion.
Ich hab irgendwie gerade geguckt, so mein Rechner ist ja echt Discontinued Oktober 2013. Ich bin ja echt... Also ist ja...
Noch neuere als meiner, ne?
Genau, ich hab ja den letzten von dieser Baureihe da damals abgestaubt. Nee, nee, nee, den werd ich hegen und pflegen so lange, wie es überhaupt noch geht. Der ist schnell, der ist toll, der hat alle Ports, die ich haben will. Das Ding, mit dem muss ich jetzt lange noch auskommen.
Mensch, USB 3.1, voll geil. Kannst auch drüber laden.
Hands gibt's doch gar nicht, 3.0 habt ihr doch, oder? Da merkst du jetzt 3.1 schon.
Na, wenn Apple da jetzt einen neuen PC da reinbaut.
Ach so, wenn, ja, wenn. Ach so, noch was, wenn ihr einen kaputten Rechner, weil er wie Hucke irgendwie Kaffee reinschüttet oder so, dann schön die SSDs aufheben, die könnt ihr schön bei eBay verscheuern. Naja, das mit dem Trim ist schon eine wichtige Sache, sonst wäre es ja alles kein Ding.
Ein Terabyte für 400 Euro. Nein, ich darf nicht.
Du hast jetzt gerade einen DiskWarrior gekauft, du musst jetzt sparen.
Und ich nehme an, die 500 Gigabyte kosten dann 200 oder 250 so, ja?
500 Gigabyte EVO. Also EVO ist ja die günstige. 231.
Der Vorteil von diesen 850 Pro und EVO, ich weiß nicht, ob es beide so sind, dass die dieses 3D-Nand irgendwie benutzen. Und ich glaube, die haben die Garantie auf fünf Jahre oder auf sieben sogar angehoben, weil die gehen nicht mehr kaputt. Man sagt ja vorher so Flash, ja, nach einer Weile und so ist es ja durch und so. Bei denen, das hält so länger oder so lange, bis die alt sind hast du, da willst du auf jeden Fall schon wieder die größere haben. Also die halten einfach.
Also your mileage may vary, weil Amazon Preise sind ja immer so... bekloppt. Das ist günstig. Ich darf nicht. Mein Rechner ist auch schnell genug.
Aber dein Mac Pro nicht.
Doch. Was?
Nee. Nein. Der hat Platten. Platten schmatten. Du weißt, wie das ist, der Moment. Also ich weiß noch, wie... Huckel hatte, glaube ich, damals schon länger eine SSD und hat immer gesagt, ihr habt alle die Sonne noch nicht gesehen. Dann dachte ich, alles klar. Neuer Rechner, Festplatte raus, irgendwie den SSD rein und... Ich hab die Sonne gesehen. Ich war geblendet. Und wenn ich nachher nach Hause komme und mein Filevolt umkopieren irgendwie fertig ist, dann... sehe ich auch die Sonne.
Dann winkst du auch noch.
Schleller Rechner, unschnelle Platte, dann geht's ab.
Wie muss man sich das dann so vorstellen? Hast du da so eine Tüte Popcorn auf dem Schoß?
Ja, dann macht er die seitliche Tür auf von dem Mac Pro und dann guckt er rein.
Dann lässt sich vom Lüfter ins Gesicht...
Und dann kopierst du einfach was.
Das hab ich auch gecheckt mit D&D.
Kommst du mit ins Kino, Dennis?
Ey, ich muss mal hier ein paar Nullen von DevZero aufs Kino.
Er hat aber nur ein Schnapsglas voll Popcorn.
Ich hab jetzt gerade wieder so ein Job, so ein ganz kleiner, und musste mich mit Xcode rumärgern. Dann machst du Xcode auf und dann röchel, röchel, ja, Index updaten. Also röchel, röchel und dann sitzt du da und wartest erst mal drei Minuten bis irgendwie dein Projekt oben ist. Und wenn ich das voll da abmache, dann macht das und es ist fertig. Oder wahrscheinlich merk ich es gar nicht, mir ist einfach fertig.
Dieses Index updaten von Xcode, das nervt aber auch überhaupt nicht, ne? Also wenn man irgendetwas macht, dann fängt er an und macht den Index neu. Und das dauert.
Nur wenn man keine SSD hat.
Ja, das stimmt natürlich. Aber selbst wenn man eine SSD hat, dauert's.
Kommt auf dein Projekt an.
Kommt auf die SSD an.
Wenn man schnell einen Rechner hat, will man auch schnell schnell IO-Durchsatz haben. Dann macht's Spaß.
Kann ich verstehen. So, ich hab noch ein paar Tipps hier. Ich glaub, so richtig Themenvielfalt haben wir heute nicht, ne? Wir müssen noch über Audio unterhalten.
So, ich poste mal die SSD hier nochmal kurz in den Chat.
Und ich hab noch ein... Du kannst ja mal vorziehen, bevor ich das wieder vergesse, wenn ich das dann so spät bringe. Ich hab ja... Wir haben uns ja vor ein paar Sendungen hier über Handschuhe unterhalten.
Ja, das war so eine Vorweihnachts-Sendung.
Ja, das ist schon eine Weile her. Seitdem ist es aber auch ein bisschen kälter geworden. Also von daher ist das Thema nicht ganz raus. Und ich hab, glaube ich, gefühlt vier verschiedene Modelle getestet. Und mir überhaupt mal so ein bisschen was bestellt und auf den Tisch gelegt.
Hast du auf deine eigenen Affiliate-Links geklickt?
Ich hab auf meine eigenen Affiliate-Links geklickt. Mal gucken, wie viel ich dabei verdient habe. Naja, ist gar nicht so einfach. Also ist wirklich erstaunlich, wie viel Dreck verkauft wird in diesem Segment.
In allen Segmenten.
Ganz neue Erkenntnisse.
Handschuhe, die so Touch-Bedienungen ermöglichen, die gibt's in allen Preislagen mittlerweile. Und ich kann euch schon mal abraten von den niedrigen Preislagen. Das bringt nämlich gar nichts. Also es hängt noch ein bisschen davon ab, wie man diese Handschuhe benutzt. Das erste Modell, was ich hatte, die einfach als Laufhandschuhe markiert waren, was bedeutet, die sind relativ dünn, haben aber dann so zwei, drei Fingertipps irgendwie in Gold und da ist dann so ein bisschen so Faden drüber genäht. Naja, das hat so am ersten Tag so halbwegs funktioniert. Aber das Problem ist, wenn die Dinger dann einmal so richtig ordentlich durchgeschwitzt sind, dann war es das auch mit der Leitfähigkeit. Da ist dann irgendwie nicht mehr so richtig viel übrig geblieben. Was aber das Kernproblem ist bei Handschulen mit Touch, ist, wie sie genäht sind. Weil womit bedienst du denn dein Touch-Device?
Mit der Fingerkuppe.
Mit der Fingerspitze.
Wenn die genau vorne eine spitzere Naht haben, ist halt voll bekloppt.
Und alle schlecht verarbeiteten Handschuhe haben ihre Naht natürlich da. Schon wenn du die Dinge anziehst, merkst du schon, dass der Abstand von deiner Fingerspitze bis zu der Spitze des Handschuhs ist einfach zu groß. Also hast du überhaupt keine Kontrolle mehr. Selbst wenn du irgendwas berühren kannst und selbst wenn da auch ein Touch durchgeht, du hast keinerlei Steuerung da drüber. Na ja, auf jeden Fall, ich hab verschiedene Modelle ausprobiert. Ich kann die jetzt gerade nicht alle runter eiern. Aber ich kann euch sagen, womit ich auf jeden Fall sehr glücklich geworden bin. Und zwar der Gewinner. And the winner is... In jederlei Hinsicht ein toller Handschuh. Von North Face. Nordfresse. Nordfresse Handschuhe. Pamir heißt das Modell. Und ich kann euch das ja hier mal zur Begutachtung geben lassen. Was schon mal auffällt ist, die Handschuhe haben auf jeden Fall Passform. Also sie sind auf jeden Fall schon mal so richtig geschnitten. Man gleitet da mit den Fingern rein und da geht was. Was denn?
Touch ID funktioniert nicht.
Ja, Touch ID funktioniert leider nicht. Aber das ist dann auch schon mal wirklich der Test, weil wenn du Touch ID eingestellt hast, dann musst du halt schnell und zuverlässig deine Nummer eingeben. Und das war einfach mit den anderen Handschuhen einfach überhaupt nicht möglich. Und das ist ein Modell, also nicht ganz billig, aber ist auf jeden Fall preislich richtig bei den Größen. Ich habe M genommen, wobei M schon relativ groß ist. Also wenn man so normal große Hände hat, dann so Männerhände, würde ich sagen, ist M schon vollkommen ausreichend. Lieber ein bisschen knapper als zu voluminös.
Was ist denn das für ein Hinweis? Artikel wird überprüft bei Amazon.
Nimmt alles kaputt. Wo steht denn das?
Da unten, diese gelbe Box.
Artikel wird überprüft, ist nicht direkt erhältlich. Kunden haben uns informiert, dass der erhaltende Artikel von der Beschreibung auf der Webseite abweicht. So, so.
Und sowas empfiehlst du uns.
Ja, sowas empfehle ich euch.
Ja, der ist ganz okay, aber ich habe auch bei dem ein bisschen das Problem, dass er nicht richtig toucht.
Na, ist halt nicht wichtig.
Also mit dem Daumen, mit dem Zeigefinger geht's.
Also erstens, hier gehen alle Finger. Zweitens, wenn du dir mal die Naht anschaust, das ist halt einfach so gelöst. Bis hinten. Ja, beziehungsweise an der Seite. Also die Fingerkuppe selber ist so ein durchgehender Stoff und vor allem das Ding ist einfach überall touch-sensitiv und nicht nur an so einem kleinen Fleckchen, wo noch was dran genäht ist. Also sie haben das so richtig in den Stoff eingearbeitet.
Aber ist der Handschuh nicht so rutschig, dass das iPhone immer irgendwie aus der Hand flutscht?
Da sind auch so Gummienoppen. Hättest du das Thema richtig angeguckt?
Hat korrekte Gummienoppen und hat auch noch so einen kleinen Clipsy, womit du die beiden Dinger zusammenhauen kannst und hat sogar noch so eine Zuglasche, also da ist einfach alles richtig. Und vor allem die Dinger machen warm. Die machen einfach warm.
Schon gut gemacht, oder was ist das hier?
Was ist das? Weiß nicht.
Oh, hier ist auch so was.
Was ist denn das?
Weiß nicht, das ist halt so eine weiße Stelle.
Keine Ahnung.
Verklebt, Dreck.
Dönersoße.
Sag mal, Tim, kann ich dich mal ganz kurz noch mit einer Metafrage stören? Ich glaube, als ich gerade Getränke geholt habe, über die Monitore kommt auch unser Sprachsignal hier gerade noch in den Raum rein. Vielleicht ist da noch irgendein Regler. Genau. Jetzt weit über weitermachen.
Keine Ahnung, was da bei Amazon gerade bestelltechnisch das Problem ist, aber das sind auf jeden Fall die richtigen. Oder ist das richtig? Hier ist irgendwas abgeschabt hier.
Wo haste dich denn da geschuppert?
Weiß ich nicht. Dunkler, so ein bisschen abgeschmoddert. Aber das sollte jetzt an der Funktion keinerlei Einschränkungen zur Folge haben. Pamir mit Windstopper. Ist total toll.
Wie du mir so Pamir.
Wir müssen diese Sendung bald beenden.
Der Wortspielindex hat doch jetzt gerade erst einmal.
Ich hab so Handschuhe, die waren irgendwie extrem billig. Deswegen kann ich mich nicht beschweren. Die haben tatsächlich so ein bisschen das Nahtproblem, aber die haben auch so ein bisschen das Problem, dass wenn man keine schwitzigen Hände hat, geht's nicht. Irgendwie liegt das, was da irgendwie leiten soll, ist irgendwie so weit drin, dass man entweder wie blöd drücken muss, damit es Kontakt gibt oder man muss halt etwas schwitzige Hände haben.
Also ich hab mich für Handschuhe aus der Quengelware bei C&A entschieden, für 7 Euro. Die waren extra für Touch. Die haben auch das Nahtproblem, aber die funktionieren dafür relativ okay. Das gibt Schlimmeres, aber Twittern funktioniert damit nicht, weil da ist die Tessatur vom Handy zu klein. Das ist halt wie, als würde man mit Würstchen versuchen, zu tippen. Aber für...
Bockwürste oder Nürnberger?
Ja, Bockwürste.
Soll ganz gut gehen mit so kleinen Würsten.
Ich hoffe, dass sich hier Bilder lostreten.
Das ist die andere Methode. Wenn es mit Handschuhen nicht geht, dann nimmst du so kleine Würstchen.
Nürnberger Würstchen gehen bestimmt gut. Frisch vom Grill.
Hält im Winter auch warm.
Ein weiterer Tipp, den ich noch am Start habe. Eine Anwendung für den Mac und für iOS. Und zwar heißt die Duett. Erst mit Duett wird es richtig nett. Hier läuft was. Was macht das? Also, was kann das? Auf dem Mac ist die Software kostenlos, lädt man sich runter, installiert man und dann hat man irgendwie so ein kleines D oben in der Menüleister. Und dann schließt man ein iDevice an mit Lightning, also überhaupt mit USB-Kabel. Und mir ist ja nicht so ganz klar, wie sie das eigentlich machen, aber man startet dann die Duet-App, die muss man halt irgendwie kaufen unter iOS. Und wenn diese App läuft, stellt sie eine Verbindung zu dieser Duet-App auf dem Mac her. Und dann wird das Ding automatisch als zusätzlicher Bildschirm angeschlossen. Und je nachdem, was das iPad so leistet, also mit meinem iPad Mini hier, mit meinem Retina, was ja relativ fix unterwegs ist, hat ich so den Eindruck, dass da keiner der Lag zu spüren ist. Also da hast du dann so richtig, wie sagen, 60 Frames pro Sekunde. Oder da kannst du dir auch richtig Filme drauf angucken. Und das ist eigentlich ganz geil, wenn du jetzt einen Laptop hast und du hast noch so ein iPad Mini dabei oder auch ein größeres iPad, dann kannst du das quasi so als Bildschirmmirror verwenden. Also wenn du jetzt so mal so auf dem Tisch was präsentieren möchtest, kannst du quasi dein iPad hinten an dein Laptop legen oder legst es irgendwo anders hin, musst halt nur mit dem Kabel irgendwie hinkommen und hast einfach einen weiteren Bildschirm. Wenn du im Mirror-Modus fährst, dann ist das so quasi so ein zusätzlicher, so ein Zweitbildschirm am Laptop.
Das ist aber irgendwie nichts Neues, sowas gab es irgendwie schon.
Sowas gab es schon mal über WLAN, so mit R-Screen oder wie das hieß. Ich hab das immer über WLAN gemacht, aber das laggt halt enorm.
Bei der alten Firma, wo ich war, da hatten wir, als die Retina Macs rauskamen, hatten wir da keinen und dann haben wir unsere Retina-Version von der Software über ein Retina iPad irgendwie getestet, weil du willst ja gucken, ob das ordentlich aussieht und das war schon sehr strange. Vor allen Dingen, weil du halt den Mauszeiger per Touch dann auch benutzen kannst, was halt irgendwie nicht so richtig gut funktioniert.
Genau, das ist nämlich noch so ein Abfallprodukt, dass du eben das Ding auch einfach dann auch per Touch benutzen kannst. Ich hab jetzt hier mal meine iPad 3. Das ist so ein. Bisschen... Adjusting Resolution steht jetzt hier drauf. Jetzt wieder alles gut. Keiner hat was mitbekommen. Aber ihr seht, hier ist so ein kleiner Mac drauf. Und dadurch, dass es irgendwie auch Retina ist, sieht das irgendwie alles ganz schick aus. Und jetzt kommt man jetzt hier irgendwie ganz korrekt drauf.
Aber streamt das Ding einfach Video rüber? Oder wie funktioniert das?
Das macht ein extra Display, ne? Also du bist ja da des Morhards jetzt nix, oder? Ne, das ist ein eigenes Display.
Also ihr läuft einfach die App im Fullscreen. Und wo du macht, einfach auf dem Mac meldet da einfach einen zweiten Bildschirm an. Oder einen dritten oder vierten oder fünften Bildschirm, je nachdem. Und ja, das performt irgendwie ganz gut.
Und geht das auch aufs Phone?
Das geht auch mit dem Phone.
Und dann kommt da wirklich so ein Mimimi? So ein Mini-Display da?
Ja, und du kannst dann auch noch skalieren, wie groß denn das jetzt dann noch sein soll. Also wenn du dann hier so auf die Systempräferenzen gehst und da Display einstellst, dann kannst du...
Und geht das auch über Remote weit weg, über IP?
Nein, nein, das geht nur übers Kabel. Und das ist halt auch der Vorteil, weil es halt schnell ist. Jetzt zeigt er mir gerade keine Skalierung an. Keine Ahnung, was jetzt hier gerade falsch ist. Hätte das auch schon mal anders. Auf jeden Fall, your mileage may vary, but it is a good solution. Und vor allem dieses Zweitbildschirm für ein Laptop, was ich eigentlich cool finde, gerade für so Präsentationssituationen, wenn du eben keinen Beamer da hast, du willst aber Leuten was zeigen, willst ein bisschen unter Kontrolle haben, was du zeigen willst, oder brauchst einfach nochmal so ein Zweitkontrollmonitor an deinem Rechner, aber hast einfach so jetzt erstmal keine Möglichkeit, das zu machen, dann ist das irgendwie ein ganz guter Weg. Also gerade für so ein iPad Mini ist das eine prima Anwendung und kostet irgendwie ein paar Dollar.
Ja, ich habe aber mein iPad leider, also nicht leider, meine Oma vermacht, deswegen kann ich das leider nicht mehr benutzen. Aber dafür ist meine Oma jetzt echt ganz begeisterte iPad-Nutzerin.
Ei Oma.
Ja, liess jetzt schon Sachen in der Wikipedia nach und so, ist voll dabei.
Ja, du hast da noch, du hast vorhin hier die Kelle geschwungen.
Ich hab die Kelle geschwungen, ja.
Was hat es denn damit auf sich?
Du meinst, wie jetzt meinst du dieses Audio-Thema oder was? Ah, eine Kelle. Metall. Jetzt ist die Kelle im Podcast besprechen. Okay, ich habe mir eine Suppen-Kelle oder so, das ist schon eine...
Das ist sehr interessant.
Eine Suppen-Soßen-Kelle gekauft für 49 Euro, glaube ich, hat die gekostet, ja. Wirklich?
50 Euro für eine Suppen-Kelle. Jetzt geht es aber ab.
Ja, ich war letztens... Ich bin ja schon so ein Koch-Freund, so Küchen-Equipment-Mos.
Warum lädst du mich nicht ein?
Ich war auch schon länger nicht mehr da.
Ah ja, muss ich mal was machen. Ich kann mir das Essen nicht mehr leisten, weil ich mir die ganze Zeit teure Rekorde holte.
Ist die Kelle aus Gold?
Nein, es ist von einer... Wie sagt man, es ist schon eine Designer-Firma, muss man wohl so sagen. Es ist halt jetzt nicht so WMF oder... Wie heißen so die Mittel?
Ich jetzt tue aber nicht so, als wäre WMF billig.
Naja, aber es ist schon tatsächlich eher so das untere Segment. Also, okay, anders nochmal, ja. Also ich mag schon gerne so in der Küche mich aufhalten und Sachen so zu bereiten und da will man halt als Nerd auch ordentliche Tools haben und so weiter und so fort. Man will als Nerd immer ordentliche Tools haben. Und in der Küche ist das ganz genauso. Und wenn man so seine erste Wohnung bezieht, dann geht man zu Ikea und kauft sich irgendwie ein paar Töpfe und ein paar Messer, ein bisschen Besteck und dann quetscht man das erste Mal Kartoffeln mit einer Gabel und dann verbiegt die sich. Und man denkt sich, ah, verstehe, deswegen war das so günstig. Oder beim Ikea-Topf fängt ihr sofort Rostflecken oder die Beschichtung blättert ab von einem Edelstahlkochtopf. Lauter so Sachen, die man dann erlebt, oder Gläser platzen, weil sie nur zusammengeklebt sind und nicht halt wirklich normal hergestellt sind. Und so weiter und so fort. Also das heißt, so in allen Bereichen, früher oder später, wenn man gerne kochen mag, dann levelt man auch ein bisschen hoch. Zum Beispiel Messer ist ja auch so ein Thema. Ordentliche Küchenmesser. Was ist das für eine Freude?
Da muss ich sagen, ich habe einen Kollegen, der hat sich irgendwann ein Messerschleifgerät, so ein elektrisches, gekauft.
Ja, aber bei Messern ist doch nur Schleifschlamm das wahre.
Moment. Und hat jetzt angefangen, Messer zu schleifen. Und tut das jetzt also schon eine ganze Weile. Und immer wenn ein Messer irgendwie nicht mehr absolut scharf ist, dann gebe ich ihm das und danach ist wieder Verletzungsgefahr angesagt.
Scharf ist aber auch nicht das Einzige, worauf es beim Messer ankommt.
Naja, schon klar.
Also die Balance zum Beispiel ist ja ganz wichtig. Und auch so die...
Verwindungssteifheit.
Genau, schönes Wort. Anyway, auf jeden Fall hatte ich so ein Besteck-Set mal von einer Firma namens Alessi. Die machen halt so Designer... Also schon ein bisschen, ja weiß nicht, gehobeneres Niveau auf jeden Fall. Und von denen hatte ich mal eine Suppenkette, die ich aus einem hier nicht näher weiter ausbreitenswerten Grund nicht mehr hatte. Und letztens hatte ich so... War ich im Car-Stadt in der Küchenabteilung, da haben die ja schon so ein paar Marken. Hab dann eine Küchenkette geguckt, eine Soßenkette oder Suppenkette, wie auch immer. Und dann gibt es halt nur Scheiß. Also es gibt entweder die, die so einen komischen rumgewrappten Metallgriff haben, wo das Wasser reinläuft und dann rostet es innen drin und irgendwann friemelt das auseinander und dann läuft alles raus. Hätte ich auch schon mal furchtbar. Oder mit Plastikgriffen ganz scheußlich. Das lässt man dann mal aus Versehen irgendwo heiß liegen. Dann schmilzt der Plastikgriff auch ganz schrecklich.
Suppenkette mit Plastikgriff?
Du glaubst gar nicht, was da die Leute mit... Was die da verkaufen, ja? Und manche waren einfach nur schlicht hässlich oder... Also ich weiß nicht, war alles nicht so meins. Ich hab mich durch die ganze Abteilung mit so einer Frau durchgearbeitet und alle Soßen, Kellen in die Hand genommen. Und war alle scheiße. Und erinnerte mich noch daran, dass in diesem Bestecksheit war wirklich eine schöne, simple, schlichte, stabile Kelle. Und die hab ich mir jetzt wieder gekauft. Und Tim fand das scheinbar jetzt erwähnt, dass ihr das jetzt auch nochmal erfahren durftet.
Ich muss jetzt mal den Link rumschicken.
Ja, kommt ja sofort.
Ich hab neulich eine Suppenkelle bei Ikea gekauft, die war aber gar nicht schlecht. Vor allen Dingen gab's die in zwei Größen. So eine mehr so Soßenkelle.
So mit Ausguss noch, oder wie?
Nee, einfach kleiner. Also so eine Suppenkelle, da löffelst du einmal und dann hast du eine ganz gute Portion Suppe. Naja, ist doch so. Es ist jetzt schwer zu sagen. Wie ist jetzt der Durchmesser? Vielleicht so vier bis fünf Zentimeter? Und dann gab es halt die aber noch so mit einem halben Durchmesser.
Ja, okay, also hier ist die Soßenkelle und ich schicke euch natürlich jetzt auch noch das Besteckset, was ich tatsächlich auch vom Design her sehr schön finde. Ähm, hier warte mal. Aber das ist mir doch zu teuer gewesen, da noch weitere Teile von zu kaufen. Ist doch nur ein Stück Blech, oder? Ja, du kannst die gerne gleich nachher noch mal in die Hand nehmen. Also die fühlt sich, die ist auf jeden Fall rock solid.
Edelstahl ist das.
Und ich stehe halt auch schon durchaus auf so die ganz schlichten Sachen. Und das muss man hier, diese Messerform hier, und da quetschst du Kartoffeln, festkochende Kartoffeln, und du machst sie einfach breit und diese Gabel gibt es keinen Millimeter nach. So muss das sein.
Allerdings, so muss das sein.
Das sind wirklich so diese Momente, wenn du irgendwo zu Gast bist oder so, und dann irgendwie bist du das geboten. Und dann so kurz unterm Tisch.
Ja, aber ehrlich gesagt, habe ich auch nie so recht die Faszination der Leute für Silberbesteck verstanden. Also ich mag Edelstahl auch viel lieber, weil das ist irgendwie, das ist hart, das ist, das läuft nicht an, das schmeckt nicht nach irgendwas und das ist einfach...
Aber Silber ist natürlich antibakteriell, das ist ja der Rumor, dass die Adeligen alle früher länger lebten, weil irgendwie alles da bei denen aus Silber war und die irgendwie total irgendwie...
Du, wenn antibakteriell wirklich dein Use-Case ist, dann hilft auch kein Silberbesteck mehr.
Ja, das ist ja auch irgendwie, keine Ahnung, ich bin da jetzt auch nicht so, ich hab das nur mal gehört irgendwo.
Ja, stimmt ja auch prinzipiell, aber ich meine...
Was noch ein Problem ist an diesem Billigbesteck ist, dass wenn du es eine Weile in der Hand hältst und wirklich auch ein bisschen Kartoffel quetschen musst, auch wenn es sich dabei nicht verbiegt, hast du dann irgendwie voll angeschnittene Hände, also angeschnitten nicht, aber diese scharfen Kanten von diesen dünnen Blechgabeln, die schneiden dir so in die Hand, dass es auch wehtut. Und ich hasse das, der Club ist voll mit diesem Billigbesteck. Mit Scheißbesteck.
Ich muss sagen, ich hab das Problem nie so sehr gehabt, weil als ich damals ausgezogen bin, hat meine Mutter irgendwie die Gelegenheit ergriffen und alles, was sie in der Küche nicht mehr haben wollte, mir gegeben und sich neues Zeug gekauft. Aber sie hatte vorher halt schon gutes Zeug. Und jetzt hat sie halt das gute alte Zeug und sie hat sich gutes neues Zeug gekauft. Also insofern...
Ich meine, bei mir ist das halt auch diese Kelle. Die fand ich schon immer toll. Und auch dieses ganze Besteckset. Und das Ding war, ich hatte die jetzt ein paar Jahre halt nicht. Und jetzt fühlst du dich wieder vollständig. Das Ding ist bei diesem Design... Also, weiß nicht, wenn ihr das schon mal hattet, wenn ihr euch mal so irgendwas aus so einer Design-Serie kauft, die euch wirklich gut gefällt. Und dann geht zum Beispiel mal irgendwas kaputt. Und dann geht fünf Jahre später wieder ins Car-Stadt oder so und will sich da noch mal ein Teil nachkaufen. Dann sagen die, ja, also die Serie, die gibt's ja schon ganz lange nicht mehr. Also da haben sie leider Pech gehabt. Und ich hab nur so auf... Also es war wirklich nur so eine Schnaps-Idee eigentlich vor zwei Abenden, dass ich dachte, na mal gucken, vielleicht... Also die gibt's schon, weiß nicht, wird bestimmt schon Jahre nicht mehr hergestellt, aber es gibt sie immer noch ein paar so zu kaufen. Und tatsächlich gab's diese Soßen kennen. Und dann war das halt so, fuck it, ich kaufe jetzt einfach.
Aber hast du jetzt auch Vorrat gekauft, wenn es die nicht mehr gibt?
Nee, die behalte ich jetzt, die nehme ich mit ins Grab.
Ich kann das sehr gut nachvollziehen. Ich bin da auch so ein bisschen latent gefährdet. Gerade so um Weihnachten herum, wenn man in diese komischen geschenkorientierten Kaufhäuser gerät. Da sind ja immer so opulente Küchenabteilungen. Das kann einem schon wirklich zusetzen. Ich bin auch mit Einschränkungen großer Fan von WMF. Ich finde, dass WMF einfach nahezu durchgehend vertretbare Qualität hat.
Ich hab das von WMF, das geht gar nicht. Du kennst doch diese Espresso-Doppelkannen, die man so schraubt. Die so irgendwie diese Ecken haben, die man so auf den Herd stellt.
Aus Alu oder Edelstahl?
Normalerweise sind die aus Alu. Normalerweise sind die so eckig. Man schraubt die so zusammen, stellt die drauf und dann blubbert es oben raus. Das ist das Normale. Von WMF gibt es so ein Ding, das hat keine Ecken, sondern ist komplett rund.
Die kannst du nicht drehen.
Und wenn du das erste Mal dieses runde Ding in der Hand hattest, dann weißt du, warum die Italienischen alle eckig sind. Weil du kannst sie nicht drehen. Und es ist umso schlimmer, je heißer das Teil ist, weil desto mehr musst du anfassen. Und je doller du das Ding anfasst, desto mehr tut es weh, wenn es noch heiß ist. Das ist das eine. Und das zweite ist, dass die das nicht hingekriegt haben, das Verhältnis zwischen Wassertank und Kaffeefiltergröße so abzustimmen, dass da nicht Plörre rauskommt. Also, wenn der Wassertank halb so groß wäre und der Kaffeebehälter doppelt so groß, würde sie super Kaffee machen. Aber so muss man irgendwie immer so mit einem Teelöffel das Wasser einfüllen und dann irgendwie noch das Kaffee-Ding bis oben in voll rammeln und dann geht's auch. Dafür funktioniert sie angeblich auf Induktionsherden. Hab's noch nicht ausprobiert.
Also ich muss auch sagen, WMF ist jetzt auf jeden Fall nicht total schlecht, aber es gibt da schon gute Sachen, aber es gibt auch immer, immer, immer was Besseres als WMF eigentlich. Also zum Beispiel bei Töpfen gibt's auf jeden Fall deutlich bessere Sachen.
Also ich hab eine Pfanne von denen, die ist schon...
Ja, wie gesagt, das ist nicht schlecht. Das ist auf jeden Fall auch besser als Ikea und definitiv schon mal ein guter Einstieg in vielleicht ein bisschen besseres Equipment, aber da gibt's schon noch deutlich Steigerungspotenzial. Ja, ja, also das, was ich von WMF habe, was mir richtig gut gefallen hat, auch designtechnisch, war ein Pizzaschneider. Der ist erstens sauscharf und zweitens hat er genau so die richtige Balance, das Gewicht und Radius umso. Jede Pizza einfach so. Ja, jetzt muss ich mal gucken, ob's den hier auf Amazon gibt. Den hab ich ja auch bei CarStarter gekauft.
Von WMF.
Pizzaschneider sieht man bei den Fahrrädern, umso größer der Radius.
Warte mal, nee, nee.
Oder der Pizzaschneider Wheeler.
Nee, die sehen nicht so geil aus. Was ist denn meiner? Ist das der Sterling? Der war schon ein bisschen teurer tatsächlich, auch der Pizzaschneider. Vielleicht gibt's den auch nicht mehr, keine Ahnung.
Bei uns in der Firma beziehen wir unsere Pizzaschneider von Joeys als Werbegeschenk.
Die sind aber wackelig.
Die sind wackelig. Zwei mal Pizza und dann kommt ja eh der nächste Neujahr.
Das ist immer nur One Way für die Pizza, die sie gerade liefern.
Ja, den, den ich hab, den gibt's bei Amazon hier so spontan nicht. Aber da lohnt es sich auf jeden Fall, auch im Kaufhaus einfach mal zu gucken und an der Klingel zu wackeln und mal die Schärfe zu prüfen und das Gewicht und das Feeling. Und dann macht Pizzaschneiden einfach so viel mehr Spaß. Und ich hab, was ich beim WMF auch hab, was gut ist, ist ein Gemüseschäler, der ist auch sau geil. Aber ja, also hätte ich gewusst, dass wir heute hier irgendwie über Küchenutilisieren sprechen, da hätte ich ja hier eine Affiliate-Link-Liste zusammenschrauben können, da hätten wir morgen noch drüber reden können.
Du hast mich ja erst auf die Idee gebracht. Aber das ist halt definitiv so was, wo Wertigkeit einfach auch mal echt zählt.
Ich glaube der Pendelschäler Profi Plus, der ist gut. So heißt der.
Der Pendelschäler Profi Plus.
Ich glaube, das ist der. Sieht sehr ähnlich aus, auf jeden Fall. Ja doch, das müsste der sein. Ich paste das mal hier rein. Das geht ja ohne diesen Riff.
Geht der problemlos in beide Richtungen?
Problemlos in beide Richtungen.
Ja, also so ein Pendelschäler legt das natürlich schon irgendwie so ein bisschen nahe. Naja, ich hab letztes Mal mir einen Pendelschäler extra bei Amazon Frankreich kaufen müssen, weil das Modell einfach nur in Frankreich zu haben war. Jetzt guck ich mal kurz, ob ich das hier noch in meiner Bestellhistorie drin habe.
Okay, ich hab auch noch einen aus Weiz.
Ah, das Mic, die Microplay.
Microplay.
Ja, die hab ich auch, ja.
Käse-Reibe, das Teil ist wirklich genial.
Das ist, das muss man wirklich sagen. Das hab ich schon mal geschenkt bekommen vom Kumpel, und der meinte so, und ich dachte mir so, okay, Käse-Reibe, okay, was ist das, was kann man jetzt noch an einer Käse-Reibe verbessern? Das ist irgendwie so ein, weißt du, so ein Ding, wo du eigentlich denkst, okay, da gibt's jetzt wirklich nicht viel, was man noch so verbessern kann. Dann hab ich das erste Mal da so meinen Käse drüber gerieben und dachte zu mir, alles klar, verstanden.
Die hat so flache...
Ja, ja, die...
Du kannst da mit der Hand drüber, du schneidest dich nicht.
Die Microplane, die macht wirklich so extrem dünne Scheiben, also so, ist mehr so wie Flocken. Schält die so von so einem Parmesan ab, das ist der Hammer. Da gehst du irgendwie dreimal mit dem Parmesan drüber und dann hast du so einen schneebedeckten Hügel auf deinem Spaghetti, das ist wunderbar.
Microplane, Amazon, der fehlt, links sind ja hier angesagt. Hier, warte, Achtung. Es fliegt gleich quasi, die Hörer denken jetzt wahrscheinlich echt so, was ist, wo bin ich jetzt hier gerade reingesetzt.
Der Pendel-Chiller ist doch nur, damit die Klinge beweglich ist. Aber den, um die Augen rauszumachen, das Ding, das stört mich immer. Den müsste man eigentlich abbrechen.
Nee, ich finde den ja praktisch, weil mach ich öfters mal, benutze ich den. Käserreibe ist wirklich macht voll Bock, damit Parmesan aufs Essen zu reiben.
Die ist unglaublich gut.
Absolut. Die Bewertung bei Amazon, die sind doch bestimmt mindestens 4,5 Sterne, 5 Sterne bei 162 Rezensionen. Also das ist ein Produkt, da geht die Sonne auf. Ein ideales Werbegeschenk für Freunde und Freunde.
Wenn sie jetzt bestellen, gibt es die Sicherheit, Tannenschuhe noch kostenlos hochzukaufen.
Ja, vor allen Dingen mein Sohn hat es ja auch noch nicht stumpf gekriegt. Also das heißt auch noch mal was.
Aber da muss man ja auch wirklich viel Käser reiben. Käser reiben.
Na ich sag mal so, wenn du öfters mal Nudeln mit Tomatensoße isst. Genau, und du hast da dann ein Stück Parmesan oder wie auch immer die Konkurrenzproduktion.
Aber es ist noch wirklich sehr trockener Käse. Es ist jetzt nicht, wenn man so Lasagne überbacken will, wo man den so ein bisschen grob oben drauf braucht, sondern den ganz ganz feinen, sehr trockenen Parmesan.
Genau, genau. Also wenn der Parmesan so wird, dass du ihn dann auch schon mit der Feile nicht mehr richtig runterkriegst, dann wird es auch mit dem Teil schwierig. Aber wenn der noch so eine gewisse Rechtsfeuchte hat, dann kannst du da wirklich richtig schön die Flocken drüber machen und die schmelzen dann sogar.
Ja, Parmesan Schnee ist wirklich toll. Also ich hab auch mich erst gewundert, so okay, jetzt krieg ich so eine Käserei, ich hab da schon eine. Aber dann, ja, kaum hat man gerieben, war alles schön. So, jetzt geht's hier los, französisch wird Amazon, jetzt kommen die richtigen Kochsachen.
Naja, wie gesagt, aus irgendwelchen Gründen gibt's diesen Pendelschneider nur in Frankreich. Ich hab auch eben nochmal nachgeschaut. Aber das Ding ist einfach der Knaller. Also das ist einfach wirklich super. Mir ist mal einer kaputt gegangen, dann muss ich dann gleich zwei nachkaufen. Aber den hab ich mir auch.
Und ist der jetzt so für Kartoffeln oder mehr so für Spargel?
Jetzt muss ich mal fragen, ich hab ja dieses absurde Problem, dass ich Linkshänder bin. Kann man den als Linkshänder auch benutzen?
Voll symmetrisch.
Super. Weil das ist zum Beispiel etwas, ich weiß nicht, ob es euch aufgefallen ist, bei Ikea, Wasserhähne. Wasserhähne bei Ikea, Kükenwasserhähne, sind alles Rechtshänderwasserhähne. Die haben alle den Einhandnüppel auf der rechten Seite. Als Linkshänder stehst du total doof da und denkst jetzt, äh?
Clemens ist doch halt mal richtig mit der rechten Hand da.
Nie.
Nie. Jetzt guck doch mal, dieser Mastrad F20039, Elios, Ebichet, Braque. Ja, ich meine, der kommt voll in iMac-Colors. Also sozusagen genau wie der orginale iMac.
Der misst halt immer so Plastik in der Küche so ein bisschen ab, muss ich sagen.
Super stabil, super geil, liegt einfach super in der Hand.
Ich hab auch einen Wasserkocher, der komplett nur Metall ist.
Aber kann ich mir vorstellen, dass der gut ist.
Der liegt wirklich gut in der Hand. Der Franzose weiß, wie man schält. Ein Wrack. Ja, aber ich bin auch nicht ganz durch. Es gibt sicherlich auch noch andere Empfehlungen. Was zum Beispiel im Bereich Brotmesser...
Oh ja...
.ist ja auch ein ganz schwieriger Bereich.
Besonders, wenn man linkshänder ist. Ja, weil die meisten Brotmesser sind asymmetrisch angeschliffen. Und wenn du als Rechtshänder schneidest, dann schält sich die Scheibe schön rechts ab. Wenn du als Linkshänder schneidest, dann schält sich das Masse schön mitten ins Brot rein.
Kannst du das nicht einfach auch andersrum halten?
Soll ich an der Klinge... Die Klinge nach hinten Richtung Körper? Hab ich noch nicht probiert. Kann ich mal machen. Ich sag's dir dann, wie es gelaufen ist.
Nein, warte mal, verstehe ich jetzt irgendwas falsch? Ich meine, wenn der Leib brot quasi mit dem angeschnittenen Teil nach rechts...
Also als Rechtshänder hast du das Messer rechts in der Hand. Der Leib ist nach links. Und du schneidest an der rechten Seite des Brotleibes. So, wenn du schneidest, dann schält sich die Scheibe nach rechts vom restlichen Leib ab. So, wenn du als Linkshänder schneidest...
Dann hast du es andersrum.
Dann hast du es andersrum. Dann ist der Leib rechts, die Scheibe geht nach links.
Aber die Klinge ist auf der gleichen Seite geschliffen.
Die Klinge ist immer noch so, dass du halt so einen Moment in Richtung Brot reinbekommst.
Das ist natürlich jetzt ein Problem, was ich so noch nicht bedacht habe.
Da schreibt jemand ganz schlimm Scheren und Dosenöffner. Ja, was auch sehr nett ist, sind Korkenzieher. Weil Korkenzieher haben ein Rechtsgewinde.
Du hast eine schwere Kindheit.
Lass es raus!
Die ganzen Jahre! Und was ich auch schon immer mal sagen wollte, was richtig scheiße ist als Linkshänder.
Nein, was ich eigentlich erzählen wollte, ich war mal in einem Linkshänder-Laden und da hatten sie einen Korkenzieher mit Linksgewinde. Und der Typ meinte, der geht weg wie warme Semmel, weil die Leute den immer gerne als Partygag kaufen. So nach Datum. Ja, in der Schublade.
Das ist so wie der Flaschenöfter, der den entscheidenden Hebel nicht hat, um den Deckel zu heben. Ja, gibt's denn Brotmesser auch für Linkshänder?
Bestimmt.
Gibt ja vieles für Linkshänder.
Tatsache, es gibt das Brotmesser, was ich gerade empfehlen wollte, auch für Linkshänder. Es tut mir leid, dass man das ohne...
Bist du schon mal ein Engländer Auto gefahren?
Ja.
Dich frag ich gar nicht.
Nein, bin ich nicht.
Schade.
Aber das ist egal beim Autofahren, ja?
Na ja, sag mal so.
Ist was egal.
Naja, ob man Linkshänder, Rechtshänder ist.
Theoretisch hätte man da als Linkshänder einen Vorteil. Aber praktisch muss man sich natürlich genauso umgewöhnen, weil du schaltest ja trotzdem auf der anderen Seite. Also...
Ich hab hier bei Spiegel, da gab es gerade so einen Artikel bei irgendeinem Amisupersportler Baseball oder was, der irgendwie so ultraviel Geld bekommen hat, da hab ich kurz reingelesen. Und dann stand tatsächlich da sein, dass er den größten Vertrag mit der größten Summe hat für einen Rechtshändler, weil es gab schon mal einen Linkshändler, der hat nochmal 5 Millionen Dollar mehr bekommen, also 215 Millionen Dollar pro keine Ahnung, 7 Jahre Baseball spielen. Das heißt, Linkshändler sind schon gefragt, aber, Roddy, also du hast da noch eine Chance.
Baseball.
Also ihr könnt das ausgleichen.
Also sag mal hier dein Brotmesser an hier.
Ja, also meine Empfehlung ist das Güde-Alpha-Olive-Brotmesser, 32 Zentimeter. Man kann das natürlich in den beliebigen Größen machen. Aber ist einfach mal geil. Ist richtig schwer, ist schon mal sehr wichtig. Brotmesser muss einfach schwer sein, muss richtig fett in der Hand liegen, weil...
Damit sein runterfällt, der Fuß auch wirklich durch ist.
Beispiel. Vor allem, ich meine, so ein Brot muss ja auch manchmal ordentlich ganz schön Wumms mitgeben. Und dann willst du natürlich dann auch schon mit so einer gewissen Masse da rein schneiden.
Und das Schlimmste ist, wenn du so ein wirklich schweres Brot hast mit so einer dicken Kruste und du nimmst dein Messer und du siehst, wie die Klinge sich so wegbiegt von. Kennst du das so? Voll eklig, weil du kannst es nicht mehr gerade abschneiden.
Genau, das heißt, das Ding muss in sich stabil sein, auch gerade über so eine große Länge.
Verwindungssteif, wir hatten das Wort.
Es muss verwindungssteif sein, genau. Und das trifft auf jeden Fall zu. Ganz nebenbei ist Güde, eine dieser Solinger Marken.
Schmeiß doch mal einen Link.
Also der Herr Güde hat das mal erfunden. Also den Wellenschliff. Ach so, den Wellenschliff. Also diese spezielle Schleifmethode für Messer mit diesen Wellen, das hat sich mal der Herr Güde einfallen lassen, da kommt das her aus Solingen. Und gibt es auch als Linkshänder-Variante. Ich werf den Link für dich gleich hinterher.
Ja, wenn soll ich die Linkshänder-Variante in meinen?
Post nur 20 Euro mehr. Ja, tut mir leid, aber so ist es. Franz Güde.
Ganz schön groß, das sieht ja mal fehlendmäßig aus.
Ja, sieht echt wirklich ganz schön fett aus.
Große Brote schneiden ist aber auch eine deutsche Sache, oder?
Ja klar, woanders gibt es ja kein Brot auf dieser Welt.
Warst du schon mal im Ausland, ey?
Na, die Franzosen haben auch große Brote bis bald.
Ja, groß, aber schmecken die auch?
Was, so Baguette der Länge nach oder was?
Nee, die haben ja auch so eine große Leibe.
Sicher, dass das nicht der Clemens war?
Du warst in einer deutschen Bäckerei.
Das ist Holland.
Ich kann dir Fotos zeigen. Also die Franzosen haben tatsächlich auch eine Brotkultur. Also die Teige sind alle... Also es gibt nicht so dunkles oder sehr... Es gibt, glaube ich, keinen Sauerteig. Aber es gibt schon echt viele leckere Brote da.
Das ist schon so ein bisschen eine Qual mit diesem Brot im Ausland.
Ich war zum Beispiel, als wir da segeln waren in Italien, da war das ganz furchtbar so mit richtig Brot. Da gibt es ja nur so Ciabatta oder...
Immerhin so Olivenbrot und so ist schon... Ja, aber...
Aber so Brot wie bei dem Italiener, wo wir mal essen gegangen sind, weil ich schon da in der Grefe-Straße... Ich meine, das ist doch schon...
Ja, das ist halt Weißbrot, ne? Aber bei den Franzosen, als wir da in Corsica auf den Markt gegangen sind, da gab es so einen Stand, ich guck mal, ob ich das Bild gerade hier irgendwo hab, da war einfach alles voll mit allen Varianten von Leckerbrot, mit Körner drauf und das alles.
Boah, wenn man eine Woche nicht gegessen hat auf Horsi, dann schmeckt einem alles. Du musst schon berücksichtigen.
Ja, warte ich so mal das Bild und lad's vielleicht mal schnell auf den Server.
Am schlimmsten finde ich ja in der Toskana dieses ungesalzene Brot. Da gab's wohl mal eine päpstliche Salzsteuer. Und seitdem backen die immer noch Brot komplett ohne Salz. Das ist so, als würdest du, keine Ahnung, in so einem Pappedeckel beißen.
Pappedeckel.
Pappedeckel. So, finish das Brot in Korsika. Ja, also das Brot, das packe ich mir natürlich. Roddy hat es gerade schon auf seine Wunschliste gemacht. Das packe ich da auch mal rauf. Nur für alle Fälle. Ja, also coole Messer sind auf jeden Fall auch immer wieder eine Freude.
Ist da eigentlich auch Messer für Brötchen?
Ich weiß nicht, was eigentlich mein Küchenmesser ist.
Weil ich zerstöre immer meine Brötchen beim Durchschneiden.
Ich hab...
Ich zerstöre meine Brötchen, weil die sind danach immer so kaputt gedrückt, weil ich schneide.
Ich hatte ja mal voriges Jahr, genau, da gab's von Zwilling so Messersets eigentlich, die sonst so im Bereich von so 400 und mehr Euro waren und die waren da gerade irgendwie so Winter-Schlussverkauf oder Weihnachts.
Da hast du mal zugegriffen.
Und da gab's eins, was dann 150 Euro billiger war und da hab ich mir mal auch so ein Messerblock von Zwilling geschossen und das ist auch auf jeden Fall schon mal sehr viel besser als alles, was ich vorher jemals hatte.
Hier hat gerade noch jemand zwei Links aus dem Plötz-Block in den Chat geworfen. Wenn ihr irgendwas über Brot wissen wollt, Plötz-Block.
Das ist dieses Brotblock, ne?
Das ist dieses Brotblock. Das ist ganz unglaublich, was der da die ganze Zeit schreibt.
Das ist sein Brotmesser.
Das sieht geil aus, oder?
Damast Brotmesser.
Das ist auch ein Kurzschwert.
Aber das ist ja ohne Wellenschliff.
Sehr lange Klinge, auch für große und runde Leibe. Du, wenn es scharf genug ist, geht das auch ohne Wellenschliff.
Ein scharfes Brotmesser braucht meiner Ansicht nach keinen Wellenschliff. Da ist was dran.
Das Ding ist ja, neue Messer sind ja immer so scharf, dass du die wirklich nur auf eine Tomate hältst und dann geht es sofort durch.
Aber wie lange?
1,5.
Kostet das Messer?
Ja.
1490 Euro, das ist noch unter 1500.
Ich war mal so frei aufzurunden.
Nach verbindlicher Vorbestellung wird mein Schmied ein neues und nummeriertes Messer anfertigen.
Mein Schmied.
Holzgriff, ganz wichtig. Das ist bei dem Güde-Messer auch so ein Ding. Das ist so ein Holzgriff, der ist stabil. Und vor allem, was bei dem Güde gut ist, da geht das, wie sagt man das, da geht dieses Messer... Hier, hilf mir doch mal kurz. Die Tatsache, dass hier sozusagen die Finger so richtig hinter dem Messer...
Ich weiß auch nicht, wie das Ding heißt.
Heft. Heißt es nicht Heft?
Naja, auf jeden Fall ist die Klinge sehr hoch und kann halt bis zum Boden runter drücken und runter sägen und landet nicht mit den Fingern auf dem Tisch. Hab ich das gut beschrieben?
Doch.
Ja, also es gibt auf jeden Fall die billigeren Messer, die haben das nicht, und dann geht die Klinge halt bis hinten ran und dann kannst du dann auch mit deinem Finger mal drunter kommen und... Dennis Fuibe. So, ich hab das Brotmarkt-Bild gefunden. Mal sehen, ob man hier auch die Brote sieht richtig. Slash Großes Bild. Guck mal hier, da gibt's die riesen Leibe. Auch. So, ab in den Chat damit. Hier, so sieht auf Corsica Brot aus. Vorsicht, das ist ein... hochauflösendes Bild. Kann man noch ranzoomen. Hier links in der Ecke, da liegen die größeren. Normalerweise gibt's da noch mehr Varianten von. Also die hatten jetzt da so eine Sorte in diesem großen Leib. Aber dafür brauchst du schon so ein Güte.
Auf jeden Fall.
Gute Güte.
Da bin ich mir noch nicht mal so sicher, ob das Güte reicht.
Na ja, wenn du das hochkant nimmst, geht das schon. Ja. Aber ja, die haben da schon Variants. Und die schmecken auch alle tatsächlich sehr gut.
Sieht ganz korrekt aus. Und hier auch mit Oliven und so. Ich bin dafür.
Soll ich mal gucken, was jetzt hier gerade mein Server an Durchsatz macht. Oh, sieben Megabytes die Sekunde. Sehr gut. Alle Brotbilder klicken hier.
Wir testen gerade deine DMG-Nummern durch.
Ja, da liegt nur das eine jetzt gerade in dem Ort. Ich hab's nur von der Festplatte kurz darauf gezogen.
Du müsstest nur das Images wegmachen und müsstest... Nee, sag ich nicht.
Also auf jeden Fall cooles Küchen-Equipment rockt. Und was halt schon manchmal eben auch bei diesen Designer-Marken passieren kann, ist, dass die halt... Wie du meintest, man schlendert so im Kaufhaus dann mal so in dieser Küchenabteilung durch und hin und wieder gucke ich dann halt mal auch so bei diesen Designer-Marken. Und dann gibt es halt auch wirklich Sachen, die einfach die so gut hinbekommen haben. Und genau nach meinem Geschmack, dann muss ich da auch mal ein kleines Stück von kaufen. Faust! Weil das ist ja...
Wir haben gerade gelernt, die Schopfkelle, oder?
Ja, stimmt. Ne, die Gabeln da aus dem Set.
Kartoffelstampfer.
Ja, Kartoffelstampfer ist auch so ein Thema.
Ja, weil das ist ja auch so ein Ergonomieproblem. Die meisten sind irgendwie so zentriert ausgerichtet, aber man kann die Kraft eigentlich gar nicht so zentriert überführen.
Eigentlich will man oben am Ende nicht einen Stab, sondern man will eher so was, wo man seinen ganzen...
Der Lorich, Panzerstamfer, äh Kartoffelstamfer. Leopard. Ja, der sieht doch sehr solide aus.
Einem Guss.
Ja, ich würde aber eher so, wenn ich mit der Hand nach unten drücke, dann ist das ja eher so eine 45°-Ausrichtung.
Eigentlich willst du gerade von oben die Kraft an.
Gerade, wenn du 45° die ganze Zeit abgeknickt hälst.
Aber musst du natürlich gerade halten, sonst knickt er dir seitwärts weg, wenn die Kartoffel...
Lass doch einfach mal deine Hand rechts am Körper so runterhängen, so dass du sozusagen maximale Energie nach unten auslösen kannst.
Aber du stehst doch nicht so in der Küche und stammst Kartoffeln. Du stehst doch vor deinem Ding so und machst es doch so von oben.
Ich weiß nicht, ich bin auf jeden Fall unzufrieden mit meinem Abschmeiß.
Schmeiß doch den Lurch noch in den Chat, der sieht doch super aus.
Der Lurch sieht interessanter aus, aber ich bin nicht überzeugt, dass der Lurch hier wirklich...
Der sieht vor allen Dingen so aus, als könnte man damit irgendwie alte Patronenhülsen noch recyceln.
Ich habe nur so einen ganz einfachen Kartoffelstampfer. Aber der regt mich auch jedes Mal auf. Aber ich stampfe auch nicht so oft Kartoffeln.
Na, es gibt ja noch so Kartoffelpressen. Das ist wahrscheinlich das, was du suchst. Na ja, also man muss ja nicht unbedingt stampfen. Man kann die ja auch durch eine Kartoffelpresse tun.
Das klingt aber so ein bisschen nach...
Ja, oder halt in Bändern.
Ja, am Ende muss eine Muß rauskommen.
Ja, naja, alles nicht so einfach. Wir werden das auf jeden Fall nochmal...
Hier, warte mal...
.fortsetzen das Thema, glaube ich, oder?
Ja, schau mal, das ist das, was ich jetzt mit der Kartoffelpresse meine. Das macht sich nämlich auch ganz gut.
Ja, hast du einen feuchten Enden, dann rutscht er immer runter an dem Ding.
Kartoffelpresse Edelstahl.
Ach, doch, zum Gnocchi machen ist das super.
Das ist interessant. Für so polnische Pierogi muss man auch Kartoffel kleinstampfen und das sieht da praktisch aus.
Also es ist so für die Leute, die jetzt keinen Chat haben und nicht klicken können, das ist wie eine Knoblauchpresse nur in groß.
Ja, in sehr groß. Damit kannst du ganze Knoblauchknollen pressen.
Damit kannst du ganze Hühner.
Knoblauchsträuche.
Damit kannst du auch Gemüsezwiebeln pressen.
Tim ist noch nicht überzeugt. Ja, ein unerschöpfliches Thema.
Ein wirklich unerschöpfliches Thema. Ich finde es großartig.
Töpfe und Pfannen haben wir noch gar nicht richtig behandelt.
Ja, Spätzle pressen und was da nicht noch... oder überhaupt so Universalmixer.
Oder die Schneidemaschinen.
Oder überhaupt so Kochmaschinen.
In der Küche, wo eine Kochmaschine steht, halte ich immer nicht viel von.
Nee, das ist für Leute, die nicht kochen können. Oder es zumindest nicht gerne machen.
Bei den meisten Küchen steht diese Maschine auch nach einem Monat, wenn alles durchprobiert ist, was in der Anleitung steht, stehen die Dinge an der Ecke.
So, wollen wir das Thema Clock Deviation noch behandeln? Oder willst du das verschieben?
Ja, nur kurz. Also da gibt es jetzt eigentlich nicht so viel zu sagen, außer dass ich jetzt halt für meinen kleinen Gitarrenpodcast war ich in Leipzig und habe den Felix besucht, der es ja wieder nicht geschafft hat auf dem Kongress. Ja, weil er arbeiten musste angeblich. Also naja, anyway, auf jeden Fall war ich da in Leipzig und habe ihn im Proberaum besucht und dann haben wir eigentlich wollten wir eine Sendung aufnehmen und halt mal Verstärker aufnehmen. Das heißt, wir haben ein paar Mikros vor einen Verstärker gehangen und dann dachte ich mir, wäre es ja super toll, wenn man jetzt noch mit so einem Zoom H1-Rekorder noch so ein bisschen Raumatmo noch dazu aufnimmt und vielleicht das so ein bisschen mit reinmischen kann, um den Soundfeder zu machen. Und dann kam ich so mit meinen Aufnahmen zuhause an und habe die ins Reaper geschmissen und dachte mir, Moment mal, da ist jetzt irgendwas komisch. Die sind ja eigentlich das gleiche Audiosignal zur gleichen Zeit aufgenommen, aber die eine Waveform ist halt so ein bisschen kürzer als die andere. Und das konnte ich mir nicht so richtig erklären. Also ich hatte das auch schon früher mal, da hat der Felix mit Ableton aufgenommen und ich mit Reaper und dann hat er mir seinen Wave geschickt und das war halt auch nicht so ganz. Und dann dachte ich mir so, aber es ist doch 24-Bit und es ist doch 48 Kilohertz. What could possibly go wrong? Also eine Sekunde ist eine Sekunde. Was machen die denn da? Und jetzt habe ich halt irgendwie, um diese Aufnahmen noch irgendwie zu retten oder bzw. diese Zweitspur vom H1 noch mit reinzukriegen, habe ich halt die ganze Zeit gesucht und nach Plugins geguckt, ob es da irgendwas gibt, was das mir wieder synkt, weil die Amplituden sind ja eigentlich da. Also prinzipiell dachte ich mir, man müsste das doch irgendwie repariert kriegen. Aber dann kam halt eine Erklärung auf, die mir jetzt prinzipiell nicht komplett unbekannt war, aber ich nicht dachte, dass man so einfach da so reinläuft, dass nämlich die Recorder oder die Audio-Devices irgendwie unterschiedliche Clock-Precisions haben. Und dann, wenn man eine längere Aufnahme macht, dann driften die halt, wenn man also wirklich zwei unterschiedliche Devices nebeneinander hält, dann driften die Clocks halt über die Zeit auseinander. Und dann ist das eine kürzer als das andere und... dann ist es scheiße.
Ich kenn das noch aus meiner aktiven Audio-Programmiererzeit. Da gab's mal so ein kleines Audiointerface, ich weiß nicht mehr wie das heißt, das war so groß wie so ein Hockey-Puck. Irgendwie so ein USB, total billiges Teil. Und das war so...
Ach, dieses durchsichtige iMac-farbene iMac oder so.
Ja, ja, so ein bisschen kleiner als diese runde Maus, die es damals gab. Und dieses Teil war dafür berühmt, dass man damit allerlei Clock-Deviation-Experimente mit anfahren konnte, weil das Teil, das war wirklich unterirdisch, was irgendwie Clock anbelangt.
Das war überhaupt unterirdisch auch, was so überhaupt Hardware-Qualität alles angeht.
Und es ist so, zumindest zur damaligen Zeit, Anfang der 2000er Jahre war das ja zum Beispiel so, dass du unter Windows nur ein Audio-Interface auswählen konntest, weil das Audiosystem unter Windows gar nicht in der Lage war, mehr als ein Audio-Interface anzusprechen, weil Clock deviated immer. Das ist einfach so. Wenn du zwei Interfaces an einem Rechner hast und die werden nicht per Hardware über, wird nicht die Clock gesynkt, was ja die teuren können, aber eben nur die teuren, dann hast du immer das Problem, dass die weglaufen untereinander. Das war damals die große Errungenschaft unter Chor Audio, dass Chor Audio das komischerweise nichts ausgemacht hat. Da hast du dann zwei Devices geöffnet, aber dann hattest du halt das Problem, dass du es selber irgendwie synchronisieren musstest. Weil dann hast du halt, wenn du das beides einfach so verarbeitet hast, hast du irgendwann mal einen Puffer-Überlauf oder Unterlauf bekommen. Also das war so, ja, ja, schöne, schöne Sache. Aber damals ist Chor Audio auch gerne dann mal irgendwie nach ein paar Stunden einfach mal für eine Sekunde ruhig gewesen und dann weitergelaufen. Die Apple-Leute konnten uns damals auch nicht so recht sagen, was das eigentlich soll. Die taten dann so, als hätten sie noch nie von dem Problem gehört.
Clock Deviation ist real.
Vor allen Dingen diese Zoom-Recorder. Ich hab dann auch geguckt, ist das jetzt ein Problem von dem Zoom-Recorder? Ich hab ja so verschiedene Engels mal bei Google versucht zu beleuchten. Und dann kommt man ganz schnell auf die ganzen DSLR-Video-Leute, die diese Zoom-Recorder oft und gerne benutzen, um halt ordentliches Audio zu ihrem Spiegelreflex-Video irgendwie zu kriegen. Und da wurde berichtet, dass der Zoom H4n besonders schlecht wäre. Und dann gab's in irgendeinem dieser Foren dann gab's auch irgendwie so ein Chart von Messungen, also wie groß der Clock Drift jetzt bei den zwischen den einzelnen Zoom-Recordern ist. Und der H4 war da irgendwie mit Abstand der größte. Der, den ich hab, war tatsächlich einer der besseren, aber ja. Und sie haben das, glaube ich, gegen das Kamera-Audio dann immer verglichen oder irgendwie so. Also auf jeden Fall ist ein reales Problem und ist auch schwer zu fixen. Das Einzige, wie man es halt fixen kann, ist, man stretcht das Audio, aber dafür muss man dann halt wieder, muss man dann resampeln oder so, ne?
Naja, du hast deine üblichen Audio-Stretching- Algorithmen, bzw. da müsste es eigentlich ohne Stretching-Algorithmus gehen, weil du ja nicht so stark stretcht, das hörst du auch nicht.
Naja, also ein Stretching-Algorithmus wirst du schon haben, egal ob du stark stretcht oder nicht.
Nein, ein Stretching-Algorithmus in dem Sinne, dass du das Audio stretcht, ohne dass sich die Tonhöhe ändert. Naja, also wenn du jetzt eine Stunde Audio um einen Prozent stretcht, oder überhaupt um einen Prozent.
Ja, hoffentlich weniger.
Naja, oder weiß ich nicht, um…
Musste keine Anpassung vornehmen.
Ja, um eine Sekunde oder zwei, dann musst du nicht keine Tonhöhenanpassung vornehmen. Das ist dann auch nicht so wichtig.
Ja, das Problem bei dem war, zum Beispiel kein Problem, wenn jetzt, sagen wir mal, ich nehme Dennis und mich auf zwei unterschiedlichen Mikros auf und über zwei unterschiedliche Audiointerfaces und wir nehmen jetzt einen Podcast auf. Dennis, du und ich zusammen. Dann ist es halt kein Problem, dieser Clockdrift, weil zwischen unseren Sätzen ist immer eine kleine Sprachpause und es fällt halt nicht so auf, dass da ein paar Millisekunden oder vielleicht noch weniger driftet. Selbst über zwei Stunden nicht. Aber wenn du mit zwei Mikros von zwei unterschiedlichen Audio-Devices das gleiche Signal aufnimmst, in dem Fall der Verstärker, dann bekommst du Kampffilter-Effekte. Dann kriegst du halt diese Phasing- und Filter-Effekte und dann klingt das einfach... Ja und es klingt dann halt irgendwie so mega weird zwischendurch. Und das ist halt dann wirklich, also da ist es dann wirklich scheiße und vor allen Dingen dann, dadurch, dass die Tracks auch noch unterschiedlich lang sind, weil auf dem Recorder haben wir halt ein bisschen später Start oder früher Start und später Pause gedrückt, also du kannst sie halt nicht perfekt einfach so auf die gleiche Länge stretchen, du musst halt dir die Waveforms angucken und dann ist das halt alles so im Fitzelbereich, das heißt eigentlich...
Und du bist ja sicher, dass es auch wirklich nicht so stretcht und nicht der eine nur ein bisschen früher gestoppt hat als der andere?
Nee, nee, nee.
Hast du auch schon gehört, ja?
Jaja, also diese...
Nee, das Ding ist, du hast ja, am Ende des Tages hast du ja in so einem Audiodevice irgendwo einen Quarz drin, der gibt dir eine Taktfrequenz vor. Und wahrscheinlich hast du einen Multiplikator, der dir die Taktfrequenz dann hoch multipliziert. Und das sind alles, das sind alles analoge Bauteile, ne? Also die haben, die haben erstens eine Serienstreuung. Wenn du einen billigeren Quarz nimmst, dann ist die Serienstreuung größer. Und zweitens mal haben sie eine Temperaturabhängigkeit. Je nachdem, wo du den Quarz einbaust, wenn da halt eine Wärmequelle ist, dann wird er halt wärmer über die, über die Aufnahme. Und dann geht, weiß ich nicht, die Frequenz hoch oder runter, müsste man mal gucken. Und so gesehen, also das ist halt, aber das unterscheidet halt die Guten von den Schlechten.
Das ist irgendwie...
Und dann dieser Clock Sync, hab ich jetzt so ein bisschen gelesen, also du kannst ja so bei den besseren Audio Interfaces, kannst ja irgendwie ein Kabel, eine Strippe ziehen und dann die Clock von dem einen als Master für den anderen nehmen, oder wie ist das? Wie funktioniert so dieses Clock Synchronization Zeug?
Kennst du die? Normalerweise gibst du halt dann einfach ein Signal von dem einen zum anderen und der andere synchronisiert sich. Also das ist so, jetzt bin ich jetzt etwas überfragt, wie das genau funktioniert.
Musstest du auch noch nicht machen, Tim, oder?
Was muss ich nicht machen?
Clock Synken. Oder wie ist das bei dir? Musst du nicht bei deinem ganzen Audio Ethernet-Geraffel irgendwo an irgendeiner Stelle irgendwie eine Clock Synken oder ist das irgendwie?
Hier müssen die Clocks auf jeden Fall gesynkt werden. Man muss jetzt unterscheiden, ob man sozusagen die internen Clocks der Geräte selber mit dem die das Audio-Hambling machen Synken oder ob du eine Übertragung synkst. Ich hab ja hier dieses Dante-Netzwerk, sprich das ganze Audio geht hier über Ethernet und da müssen sich dann die Clocks der einzelnen Rechner halt über das Netzwerk miteinander synken und das ist ein entsprechendes Protokoll.
Du hast ja eigentlich nur ein Audiogerät, das ist ja der Mixer, da geht ja alles rein. Also du hast ja keine weitere Analogquelle jetzt an dem Rechner über ein zweites Interface. Sonst hättest du das Problem auch, und zwar recht massiv. Siehst du, sobald du halt zwei getrennte Audio-Interfaces hast mit zwei Analogquellen, hat jedes Audio-Interface seine eigene Clock. Und die laufen auseinander.
Wenn man es nicht syncet.
Ja gut, aber die syncen sich ja dann eben über das Protokoll miteinander.
Wenn man so eine Geräte hat, die das können, ja. Also der Zoom H1 oder H4 oder was auch immer, die haben natürlich keinen Clock-Sync-Interface. Also was heißt natürlich, sie haben es einfach nicht.
Ja gut, ich hab mich vorhin auch falsch. Die beiden Sachen sind natürlich im Prinzip schon dasselbe. Eine Clock eines Gerätes muss sich halt auf die andere einstellen lassen, worüber auch immer sie sich sügen. In diesem Fall sügen sie sich halt über das Internet-Protokoll, was da gefahren wird. Und es gibt entsprechende Master- und Slave-Clocks in diesem System, die sich halt dann auch, wenn die Master ausfällt, auf eine andere einigen könnten etc. So läuft das halt bei mir. Nicht, dass ich hier immer Erfolg mit habe.
Mobile Macs, BZW, Freak Show berichtete.
Es gibt neue Treiber und so. Problematisch ist es halt so bei Skype, wenn du so riesige Laufzeiten hast und das da gar nicht mehr um einzelne Samples geht, sondern teilweise auch um Sekunden.
Ja gut, aber das Problem ist ja dann schon im digitalen Bereich. Also wenn dir halt ganze Pakete verloren gehen und Skype das irgendwie hinfudget und Sprechpausen benutzt, um mal ein bisschen weniger Datendurchsatz zu machen und dann wieder Audio und Video wieder synchronisiert und so. Eigentlich möchtest du gar nicht genau wissen, was die da alles tun.
Also auf jeden Fall ist die Lesson learned. Kinners, nehmt mit dem gleichen Audiointerface auf alles, was ihr könnt und dann ist alles gut. Nehmt nicht mit zwei unterschiedlichen Audio-Devices das gleiche auf.
Man kann das schon machen.
Du kannst es zwar schon machen, aber dann wird es halt kacke.
Na Final Cut Pro X hat ja explizit solche Synchronisationsmechanismen eingebaut. Da kannst du dann sozusagen wirklich noch das Zusatz-Audio einfach so zum Filmen zulegen und sagen...
Ja, das ist auch ein cooles Feature, aber das gibt es halt nur in Final Cut oder als semi-teure Extra-Software, aber die gibt dir dann halt nicht so die gesunkenen Spuren wieder her. Also du kriegst es dann schwer nur wieder raus in deine DAW oder so.
Ist halt blöd.
Also es gibt...
Das weiß ich jetzt nicht so ganz genau, wie schwierig das ist.
Also du könntest zwar aus Final Cut wieder die einzelnen Audiotracks rausrendern, aber es ist halt auch... Also ich hab's noch nicht probiert. Ich müsste mal jetzt die beiden Tracks da reinlegen und mal gucken, ob das Final Cut das so hinkriegt, dass es dann eben nicht so diese Camp-Filter-Effekte...
Also ich hatte da einmal gute Erfahrungen.
Aber hattest du auch so einen Fall, wo sozusagen genau dieses Problem auftrat?
Ich weiß nicht mehr ganz genau, was die Quelle war. Ich möchte glauben, dass das was mit Skype zu tun hatte, aber ich weiß es nicht mehr so genau.
Ah, übrigens eine Sache, die ich noch sagen wollte. Zum Abschied fast schon sind wir ja bald. Also einerseits hatte ich ja mal vor langer Zeit gesagt, ich hatte diesen Glyph, dieses kleine iPhone-Stativ. Da gibt es jetzt übrigens eine neue Version von und die funktioniert jetzt auch einfach für alle iDevices oder sogar auch Androids, weil die das so ein bisschen verstellbar gemacht haben. Also du stellst...
Du funktioniert vor allem nicht nur mit dem nackten Gerät, sondern mit beliebigen Covern.
Ja, genau, der neue Glyph.
Wie heißt der Glyph?
Glyph-Tripod-Mount. Genau, den gibt's jetzt in Variabel. Super kleines Tool, um mal mit seinem iPhone oder so mal was auf dem Stativ zu schrauben. Und dann hatte ich euch ja versprochen, hier meinen neuen Lieblings-Twitter-Account zu featuren. Also zwei. Mein Lieblings-Twitter-Account 2014, hatte ich glaube ich auch schon gefeaturet, ist dieser History Picks. Warte mal, wie krieg ich jetzt hier die URL davon hin? Da sind immer einfach echt coole Fotos, historische, was auch immer. Wer dem noch nicht folgt, der hat es irgendwie voll mal nicht drauf. Hier ist der Link dazu. Und dann der zweite Twitter-Account, der mich doch jetzt in letzter Zeit öfters erfreut, ist, wie geht das hier? Fascinating Witz, den kann man nicht so richtig gut folgen, den kann man nur ab und zu mal anbrausen, weil der retweetet halt auch echt viel Krämpel. Aber der hat immer so von Wine, heißt das wine.com? Wo diese Kurz-Video-Clips, diese, genau, wo er sich da die besten animierten Gifts oder Kurz-Video-Clips einfach so zusammensammelt und da sind einfach, ich hab mich da schon teilweise absolut checkig gelacht, abends wenn man mal was geraucht hat, dann kann man mit diesem Twitter-Account durchaus auch mal zwischendurch Spaß haben. Da gab es zum Beispiel eine Serie, die müsste ich hier gleich mal noch verlinken, damit die Leute einen guten Start haben, und zwar die sieben besten Gifts, die rückwärts viel besser sind als vorwärts. Warte mal, wo waren die? Ja, die waren richtig gut. Warte mal, ich muss mal hier auf den, die klicken wir jetzt noch zusammen durch, oder? Okay, ich pack dir jetzt einen Chat, alle nochmal tief an der Zigarette ziehen und so jetzt, hier, klick mal da, Tim. Also das ist hier der erste, den find ich schon richtig geil, weil das dreht einfach so die ganze, die ganze Storyline halt um. Na, das ist halt Aladdin, ja, rückwärts. So, und es fängt halt so anders so wie die Kids. Ne, er nimmt ihm quasi das Brot weg, behält es für sich und der Affe guckt gehässig rüber. Und es ist einfach so ein geiler, geiler Fnord. Und der hier ist auch einfach super. Ein bisschen makaber vielleicht, aber.
Schieben sie den unters Auto.
Das ist ja jetzt genau das Richtige für Audiopodcasts.
Aber die klicken jetzt einfach auf diesen Link in den Show Notes. Der ist auch schön.
Der Hund legt die Pizza zurück.
Und vor allen Dingen aber auch mit diesem kleinen, warte, warte, warte, mit diesem kleinen so, stupsa noch. Liegt noch nicht ganz richtig wieder drauf.
Ich hab schon den Eindruck, dass es so der Wichtige ist. Ich muss dir erklären, wie machen wir das?
Da ist die Manzuckerwatte rückwärts halt. Das müsst ihr euch einfach angucken. Klickt einfach.
Mit dem großen Augen.
Das ist mein Liebling, weil der so total subtil ist. Irgendwie ein Mädchen lacht sich eins und plötzlich so wupp.
Das kommt überhaupt nicht vorbei jetzt vom Podcast.
Der ist irgendwie nicht so geil.
Wer taucht ab?
Das ist der Klassiker, ne? Ja, aber das mit dem...
Auf den Schaukel zu springen.
Zuckerwatte war, glaube ich, jetzt...
Zuckerwatte hat es jetzt gerissen, glaube ich.
Ja, solche Sachen gibt es halt bei Fascinating-Wits unter anderem. Das ist immer mal wieder eine Reise wert.
Solche Sachen gibt es nur bei Huckel eigentlich.
Das war das Sendegate jetzt hier. Ende?
Im Gelände.
Ende im Gelände.
Schluss mit Fax.
Ja, wir haben alles erzählt und in dem Sinne leiten wir das unvermeidliche Ende der Freak-Show ein.
Relativ früh würde ich sogar sagen.
Relativ früh heute. Wir sind auch alle total durch.
Ich muss sagen, ich bin wieder fit geworden während der Sendung.
Ja, ich merke schon.
Die Kelle hat es gerissen. Die Kelle geschwungen.